Und das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Okay, girl, du kannst auch jetzt
aber ich habe massiv massiv pippo fett zeug am start
nee ehrlich gesagt ist das gar kein pippo fett zeug das ist husten bonbons
bin mir nicht sicher ob ich ein husten bonbon kauen kann während ich rede im
stream das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren ob das funktioniert bin mir
da nicht so ganz sicher wir testen wir testen das jetzt mal
hals ist besser aber noch noch nicht gut also wahrscheinlich ist pünktlich
wenn ich wieder arbeiten gehen muss ist mein hals wieder in ordnung ja ich ich
habe ich ich ich habe vorgestern gestern vorgestern ich glaube gestern vorgestern
vorgestern habe ich angefangen ein stellenanzeigen video aufzunehmen aber
ich habe schlicht und ergreifend zumindest stellenanzeigen deswegen
müssen wir uns heute mal ein paar besonders peinliche raussuchen
so also ich probiere das jetzt mal ob ich ein husten bonbon lutschen kann im
stream ohne dass es zu nervig wird sowohl für mich als auch für euch
probieren das mal aus weil ich mein zum größten teil kann ich mir das hier in
die backe stecken
keine ahnung ob das ob das gescheit funktioniert wenn ich wenn ich muss ich
das nebenhin legen habe heute dein lock 4j hack ja lock 4j hack ist vielleicht
übertrieben von dem video oder das ist ich mein ich habe ich habe gezeigt man
das ausnutzen kann er wird ja gar nichts gehackt ist ja kein hack in content
muss man ja auch mittlerweile auf youtube dabei sagen und wie kam es an
kannte jemand außer dir das video schon als ihr das geguckt habt
vor allem was hat ein lehrer denn gesagt dazu
oder bist du der lehrer das kann ja sein auch man
die bonbonsacken was ist für ein krab das sind bonbons mit füllung leute
kennen das wenn ihr einfach nur einem bonbon lutschen wollt und auf einmal hat
das ding wenn ihr ein bisschen drauf beißt bricht es auseinander und hat
eine füllung die sind nicht geil ich mag das nicht ich will weit ich will
weiter lutschen mein ziel ist es ja nicht irgendwie
füllung im mund zu haben sondern ich will weiter weiter weiter lutschen für
den hals nintendo christmas christmas musik gucken wir mal was ist so viel
hyper gachi im chat was denn los massif hyper gachi exzellent alles ganz gut ja
es wird mich interessieren was ich gerade gesagt habe
es ist nicht rikola das ist m eukal nur echt mit der fahne warum auch immer so
ein bonbon eine fahne braucht ist mir vollkommen unbegreiflich aber nur echt
mit der fahne blutet
dankeschön 22 monat subscription ja aha gachi role leute ich habe noch was
mal auf jetzt nämlich aufgefallen ich muss mich mal unbedingt drum kümmern dass
ich mehr mots kriege mal guck mal also wenn das mit dem bomb auch nicht geht
sagt bescheid leute ich habe noch insgesamt 25 25 stell euch das mal vor
im out slots frei reguläre 15 15 in maus da können wir so viel zeug noch machen
so jetzt setze ich mich mal hin
ok ok po g wenn ihr eigentlich mal ein poc po g sagen was er hat kein plan was geht
new world geht er weiterhin voll durch die decke
wettfried hatte free weekend und ist jetzt wieder dauen
pepo rage die mod welches denn warum hier wird doch selten genott stonks ja
also wenn eine sache not stonks ist dann das hier kommt mal hier
du musst es erst mal schaffen release minus 32 30 so schlecht
pepo hey stimmt ja das mache ich rein das finde ich ganz gut
naja es ist aber schon ganz schön bitter oder und wie lange das noch
wirklich 100.000 aktive sind warten wir mal ab aktuell schießen sie ja ein bock
nach dem anderen ich weiß nicht ob ihr das mitbekommen
hat habt aber anscheinend hat pepo hey wir machen jetzt ist als emote rein muss
es nur hier pepo hey ist geedet ffz add to my channel
warum geht es nicht warum ist es broken ffz leckt alte ffz leckt hardcore warum
leckt ffz denn so ich kann es nicht enden ich habe auf adden probiert mal ob es
geht pepo hey kann ich machen angeblich ist es drin
die lauter mann sekunde pepo hey mehr funktioniert nice pepo hey doch geht
geht
emote activated ihr müsst den chat refreshen um zu gucken ob es funktioniert
das kann das kann ffz wohl noch nicht das on the fly reloaden was ich nicht
verstehe die können ohne problem die ist nicht schlecht die können ohne
probleme ffz eigentlich updaten lassen alle paar oder vielleicht machen sie
das ja auch alle paar minuten
weiß man ja nicht
teams woge habt ihr eigentlich schon gesehen dass wir jetzt er kriege haben
ich bin das ding richtig geil weiß ich warum aber irgendwie mag ich das die
maut so ein bisschen nische hat kaum eine aktiviert aber ich finde das gut
er kriege
ja aber für das akri haben wir haben wir genug von pains champ bis sonst was
die ist die frauenquote bei euch auf der arbeit wie groß möchtest du das wissen
vom radius her und ich meine jetzt als radius nicht die fläche sondern wie
teamübergreifend möchtest du das wissen
also im team in der abteilung in der gesamten firma sicher nur IT der IT ist
quasi gesamte firma
also ich kann dir sagen bei mir im team bisschen laut
also bei mir im team ist nicht eine frau wir hatten mal zwischenzeitlich eine
die sich um also wir hatten schon das stimmt nicht wir hatten wir hatten sogar
schon insgesamt hatten wir sogar schon mal zwei stück wir hatten eine die sie
um datenbanken gekümmert hat die kam aus russland gekommnet ist jetzt auch
immer noch da aber woanders und dann hatten wir noch eine andere die war aber
schon ein bisschen älter die hat sich um wie nennt man das so so tickets tickets
verteilen und organisations sachen
gekümmert ich habe immer dazu gesagt ticket schubserin weil ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht genau wusste was jetzt ihre ihre aufgabe war aber aktuell haben wir
nicht eine frau im team so mal das jetzt weiten wir das mal ein
bisschen vielleicht machen heute abend einfach auch nur laberstreben anstatt
aber ich muss stellen anzeigen ich muss stellen anzeigen raussuchen weil ich
brauche welche ich habe zwei gute ich habe zwei gute für das video schon aber
ich brauche ein bisschen mehr also wenn ihr übrigens beide bevor ich jetzt
anfangen mal ein bisschen laberstellen falls ihr gute stellen anzeigen habt die
ich mir mal angucken soll sowohl gut im positiven sinn als auch im negativen
sinne also es kann auch sehr schlecht sein
könnt ihr mal schicken gucke ich gucke ich mir die mal an so und ansonsten
sagen wir mal so abteilungsübergreifend haben wir tatsächlich einige weil die
ganzen ios und mech entwickler sind gefühlt 80 prozent frauen bei
datenbanken haben wir auch zwei stück im software test team haben wir eine also
insgesamt es ist gar nicht so schlecht bei uns wo man halt mal es halt auch sehr
auf den bereich ankommt wo man zum beispiel sehr viele haben aber das ist
wahrscheinlich überall so ist personalabteilung weiß ich wie es bei
euch aussieht frauenquote personalabteilung chat also bei uns 80
prozent 80 prozent frauenquote der personalabteilung
bei uns sind alles frauen in der personalabteilung außer der chef
es kommen bestimmt wieder welche sagen jaja das patrick schart schlägt wieder
zu wir haben aber wir sind da tatsächlich relativ fortschrittlich
wir haben schon seit ewigkeiten eine frau im was ich ob das der vorstand ist
also auf oberster management ebene dort wo es glaube ich nur fünf leute gibt da
haben wir schon seit über 15 jahren frau dabei also da war schon war schon
relativ gut insgesamt gut IT technisch muss man natürlich sagen
wie überall ist jetzt der frauenanteil bei uns nicht sonderlich hoch
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen ich finde es auch nicht schlimm ich bin einfach da
manche leute sollen das machen wo sie spaß dran haben und nachdem sich halt
einfach nicht so viele frauen dafür interessieren gibt es halt weniger
man was willst du machen da machst du nichts dafür hast du bestimmt andere
berufe da bist du irgendwie als mann in der in der in der minderheit
wahrscheinlich ganz drauf an wo man guckt aber wie gesagt bei uns ist gar
nicht so schlecht mit frauenquote aber riesige riesige mehr zahlen ist
natürlich immer noch männer
frauenquote in form von einer festen zahl halte ich persönlich nichts von
solltest allen leuten ermöglichen dass du machen was sie machen wollen aber im
menschnummer bereiche gibt entweder männer mehr ansprechen und andere
bereiche die frauen mir ansprechen warum soll man da irgendwie großartig was
reglementieren so lange jeder die chancen hat das zu machen was er machen
will ja twitter ist immer geträgert das normal bei uns wir hatten lassen wir
überlegen in der berufsschule
drei drei stück hatten wir in der berufsschule wir waren auch so um die
30 wir hatten eine die hatten nichts gecheckt die hat also wie gesagt alles
fachinformatiker systeme dekoration die hat wirklich nichts gecheckt ich weiß
nicht wie die in den beruf reingeschlittert ist der fernes halber
jetzt ich will nicht weibliche fachinformatikerinnen
bashen wir hatten auch genug männer oder kerle in unserer berufsschule die von
tuten und plasen keine hand ist vielleicht taktisch die wort weil
etwas schlecht gewählt aber die absolut keine ahnung hatten von dem was sie
machen
beste beispiel war immer noch ein deutscher mein bonbon gleich gleich
gelutscht
bestes beispiel in der berufsschule war immer noch einer der war vorher wie
nennt man das steinmetz der war steinmetz und dem ist ein keine ahnung ob es ein
grabenstein war irgendein großer brocken stein ist dem auf den fuß gefallen
und dann konnte er konnte er nicht mehr steinmetz sein weil er nicht mal ich
richtig laufen konnte oder so und danach ist er fachinformatiker geworden ich
finde schon relativ weiter sprung vom steinmetz also sein ich glaube er hätte
einen deutlich besseren steinmetz abgegeben als fachinformatiker weil von
fachinformatiker sachen hatte der absolut kein plan warum der fachinformatiker
gemacht hat und das fand ich tatsächlich gut sein damaliger chef dort wo er
gearbeitet hat da wo ihm dieser dieser betriebsunfall passiert ist hat ihm
quasi durch vitamin b die ausbildungsstelle zum fachinformatiker
vermittelt die sache war nur die da hat wirklich keine ahnung ab das war nicht
für den richtigen beruf das war echt nicht der richtige richtige beruf
der hat es auch geschafft in einer datenbankarbeit das habe ich euch
glaube ich schon mal erzählt recycle story leute der hat es geschafft in einer
datenbankarbeit 2 von 100 punkten zu schreiben weil er zweimal create table
geschrieben hat zweimal create table gab zwei punkte 2 von 100
wisst ihr null von 100 null von 100 würde ich ja noch verstehen
das ist einfach nicht gemacht arbeitsverweigerung aber 2 von 100
musste erst mal schafft ich mochte den keil aber da war der war wirklich sehr
nett ich habe ein paar mal noch nach der beruf schon mit den paar e-mails
geschrieben damals aber ein bisschen aus den augen verloren
der war echt nett wünsche mal wissen was aus dem geworden ist
name weiß ich noch könnte ich gucken aber jetzt nicht im stream
stell dir vor du gibst dir mühe machst 2 von 100 jahre hat mir schon ein bisschen
leid getan der hat sich der hat sich mühe gegeben
das war kein mann da kann ich mich dran erinnern das war echt kein mann der
großen worte
von dem habe ich irgendwie nur durch zufälle erfahren dass er glaube ich in
der hessischen ich glaube hessischen rudermannschaft ist oder so der war
sogar richtig gut was das angeht der hat aber nie was erzählt
naja aber fachinformatiker war echt echt nicht sein sein spezialgebiet
habt ihr schon länger her mal welche geschickt das weiß ich nicht mehr
wo hast du mir die geschickt ach so hatten wir uns die schon eingeguckt im
stream er konnte alles außer fachinformatiker sachen
hey ja das war das war tatsächlich ganz lustig wann war wann war europameister
oder weltmeisterschaft in deutschland 2006
alles sein genau da waren wir zusammen da waren wir zusammen das weiß ich nicht
da waren wir zusammen damals mit den leuten aus der berufsschule da waren wir
zusammen bei public viewing und wir waren vorher frankfurt hauptbahnhof das ist
by the way der ekligste der ekligste mcdonalds den ihr kennen können könntet
vielleicht waren wir bei mcdonalds ok gibt es anscheinend keine bilder davor was
man da halt so macht und der typ ich hätte nie von ihm gedacht das war der
krasseste checker überhaupt wir haben gesagt er lasst noch mal schnell aufs
klo bevor wir zum public view hingehen und was macht er ist natürlich wie
immer männer klo kannste rein frauen klo irgendwie schlange bis die treppe hoch
leider leider ist da kein bild von innen also dieser mcdonalds von innen ist
tatsächlich echt eklig doch hier das ist er doch das ist wirklich eklig am
hauptbahnhof zumindest zumindest richtig krasseste checker während wir aufs klo
gegangen sind hat er sich irgendwie an die an die
mädchenschlange gestellt und hat einfach nichts gemacht und hat jeder
angegrinst und als wir wieder rausgekommen sind aus dem klo hat er
irgendwie zwei middels schon am start gehabt mit denen er da irgendwie rum
rum wie sagt man das rum geschickert hat ja der war echt das war der krasseste
checker aller zeilen richtig richtig wie sagt man heute sigma mail
keiner der hat es aber geschickt gemacht der hat einfach nichts gesagt
das ist einfach nur gut aus weiß man als ruderer sie ist ja auch war gut
trainiert hat sich einfach nur hingestellt und hat geguckt wie quasi
nicht abgeholt und das hat anscheinend die mädelste angesprochen und hat er
schon gleich zwei am start gehabt der war geiler tüber ich habe das nie
gecheckt bis er mir irgendwann mal das erzählt hat dass er irgendwie in der
hessischen rudermannschaft ist oder so der war der war cool generell ich muss
sagen ich hatte da echt glück es waren paar echt nette leute bei mir in der
berufsschule es waren ultra viele spasten das muss ich jetzt an der stelle
auch noch mal sagen so richtig nervige leute kennt ihr das die quasi immer und
überall raushängen lassen müssen dass sie sich von niemand was sagen lassen
und quasi quasi sobald man da auch nur zweifel daran haben kann dass das muss
sofort demonstriert werden ich habe da mittlerweile überhaupt
keine schmerzen damit wenn ich wenn ich mal sagen kann ja ok dann ist es halt so
auch wenn ich weiß der andere hat nicht recht denke ich mal dass die diskussion
ist es mir gar nicht wert dann hatten wir auch immer leute die
haben es ja mit den berufsschullehrern angelegt und so was das waren so
nervig und fahnen waren es irgendwelche kinders irgendwelche 17 jährigen oder
so halbe hemd ich meine ich war wie alt wie alt wie alt war ich 2007 ich war
gefühlt doppelt so alt als die meisten in der berufsschule und aber ein
richtiger debten dabei aber ich hatte ich hatte echt glück es waren paar
wirklich äußerst äußerst nette leute bei mir in der berufsschule mit mit so
drei stück wie gesagt mit dem ruderer noch zwei anderen hat danach noch ein
bisschen kontakt aber das hat sich jetzt auch so im sand verlaufen leider wird
mich echt mal interessieren was da was da aus den geworden ist
ja gut ja ist so aber wie gesagt bei uns ist die 70 prozent oder so der app und
mac entwicklung sind medels ansonsten gibt es wenige bei uns generell muss man
sagen ich glaube das ist bei vielen banken und also in frankfurt so der fall
wir haben natürlich in der it nicht nicht übermäßig viele medels insgesamt
ist die frauenquote bei uns glaube ich gar nicht so schlecht also über alle über
alle abteilungen drüber weiß jetzt nicht wie viel gab es letztens eine mail
aber hat sich relativ hat sich relativ ausgeglichen aber was bei uns halt
wirklich heftig ist das durchschnittsalter das durchschnittsalter
ist irgendwie 43 oder so stelle euch mal vor ich bin mit 37 unter dem
durchschnittsalter das kann man sich gar nicht vorstelle
aber das ist halt frankfurt banken stonkstinger kein wunder dass die
alle so rückständig sind wo soll das auch herkommen
bei euch ist irgendwas um 50 noch heftiger tja das wäre was da hatten wir eine da hatten
wir eine in der berufsschule wobei ich glaube bei der war das auch
nur getue ich wäre bis heute nicht sicher wie gesagt wir hatten wir hatten in der
berufsschule drei medels werden eine die hat gar nichts gecheckt wie gesagt werden
genug keller die auch nichts gecheckt haben werden eine die war ganz gut und
werden noch eine die war ganz gut und die eine sah wirklich aus wie ein kerl aber
dann ist ja nicht schlimm ist gerade gerade in der heutigen zeit wirklich
nicht schlimm ist bei einem ich dachte aber am anfang das ist ein kerl bis ich
bis ich dann gehört habe dass ich sag den namen ist nicht aber wichtig ist an
stimme gehört haben vornamen gehört habe habe ich auch okay aber die war
wirklich nett muss man sagen also gar nicht so wie man sich das da
vorstellt bei der optik mit der habe ich mich sogar mal verabredet
ich weiß jetzt habe ich mir auch schon mal erzählt die cycle story
der habe ich mich sogar verabredet später so im dritten ausbildungsjahr 200
dritten ausbildungsjahr die war wirklich nett
metal girl ja tatsächlich das war war tatsächlich hartrock grill
nehmen darf ich tatsächlich verabredet im 200 dritten ausbildungsjahr war das
naja
hat aber nix eing fiquei
Tja, manchmal kommt dann alles zusammen.
100xCreatable 100 Punkte, ja das hätten wir mal ausprobieren müssen.
Aber es waren ja nur zwei Aufgaben und bei beiden Aufgaben hat man Createable gebraucht.
Twitter, jetzt eben gerade oder schon länger her?
Twitter, ne schon länger her.
Achja nice, ich glaube hat es so geschrieben, ja richtig richtig hier, ähm, ich habe übrigens
Patrick, ich habe bei uns mal gefragt, es gibt leider kein, so Mitarbeiter vermitteln,
Mitarbeiter für Partner, ich bekomme leider kein Geld dafür, dass ich ihn quasi vermittelt
habe.
FeelsBadman, wäre doch mal gut oder?
Chat, Chat, ich weiß ich habe hier richtig viele schlaue Leute.
Ich sollte irgend so ein Personalvermittlungs Ding machen und dann vermittel ich den Q-Chat
an alle möglichen Firmen und dann Big Stonks und wir haben ja alle die Macht der quasi,
das kognitiven Prime-Sub-Hive-Mines, das heißt wenn einfach nur genug Leute subscriben, steigt
der IQ von allen, das heißt wenn ich euch, der Job-Champ, genau, wenn ich euch vermittel
und einfach nur genug Prime-Sums reinpumpe, dann seid ihr alle so schlau, dass ihr das
easy macht.
Agile, Agile-Job-as-a-Service, genau, ja, das stimmt, ah ja, jetzt, jetzt habe ich
Fat-Fitter bekommen, exellent, ach das, Moment, ok, das habe ich ja schon wieder ganz vergessen,
das ist ja richtig nice, das können wir gleich mal aufmachen, Sekunde, jetzt wird es christlich
Leute, weihnachtlich, passt doch richtig gut, Church-Tools, das heißt allen Ernstes so,
die Website, Church-Tools, Company, Jobs, Prager, Leute, Prager, eine Runde, ich brauche
Sekunde, ich brauche Prager, ich glaube ich habe noch Bless-RNG irgendwo, aber das darf
man ja nicht mehr zeigen, Moment, braucht es jetzt passend, WTF, ich sollte Prager hier
besser nicht aufmachen, stelle ich gerade fest, Sekunde Leute, ich brauche mal kurz das passende
Mode, Prager, so, ja, Bless-RNG gibt es ja nicht mehr, eine Runde Prager, ok, was, ok,
Primer, habt ihr mitbekommen, dass Prime-Video gebannt wurde, Hä, wie jetzt, komme ich mir
gleich wieder an, Hä, was, was, Twitch sperrt Prime-Video
Kanal, das ist der Krone, die haben sich selbst gebannt, es-do-es-un-latte, was heißt
denn das, was heißt das auf Deutsch, das ist spät, schon spät, ist das das Bedge-Format,
schon spät, hahahaha, geil, null, das kann es doch kein, das geht doch nicht in den Ernst,
das ist doch Fake, das ist doch Fake, das kann doch nicht sein, ist das Earth, was, sag
ich denn, also ich hab nur die Wahl, entweder schalte jetzt ab oder ich zeige meine Brust
und wir werden gebannt, hahahaha, was, hahahaha, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
dass eh jeder gerade den 2. Tab auf hat und googelt nach dem Clip, wo die Buba macht.
Ich weiß es jetzt schon, ja. So, man nennt es schlecht. Ok, aber Leute, es wird christlich.
Offene Stellen bei Church Tools. Backend Entwicklung, Systemadministrator, Webdesigner.
Jetzt Buba vorbei, jetzt wird Preige. Christlicher Weihnachtskontent. Moment,
es hat gerade eine Link dazu gepostet auf Twitter. Moment, das muss ich mir mal kurz angucken,
aber auf dem zweiten Rechner. Die zieht sich wirklich das Teil hoch.
Da sieht man noch gar nichts. Da sieht man noch gar nichts.
Aber Leute, jetzt wird es kreusch hier. Es gibt Jobangebote zu Weihnachten bei Church Tools.
Preige, Leute, Preige. Zeigt mal bisschen. Keine Ahnung, was das richtige Wort für ist.
Kirchenwerkzeug, Preige. Zeigt mal löblich jetzt. Also, Systemadministrator und Systemadministratorin
für unser junges christliches Unternehmen. Das Tools für den nächsten Kreuzzug sozusagen.
Ok, was haben wir als nächstes zu bieten? Also. Ich bin nur drauf gekommen, als einer
einen Chat geschrieben hat. Ok, also, zeig mal her.
Vollzeit oder Teilzeit an unserem Standort in Karlsruhe oder Remote, das ist schon mal
gut. Das ist schon mal gut, dass Remote am Start ist. Die Kirche muss auch mit der Zeit
gehen. Und gerade die Kirche, die soll ja Remote gut dabei sein. Dann vielleicht Leute
im Himmel rekrutieren oder so. Keine Ahnung. Gibt bestimmt ein paar richtig big brain Leute.
Also, als Team von Christen arbeiten wir gemeinsam für Gottes Reich und setzen dabei auf die
Gaben jedes einzelnen Mitarbeiter. Jeder einzelne Mitarbeiterin. Die gebündelte Leidenschaft
für unsere Ortsgemeinden und Gottes weltweite Gemeinde ermöglicht es uns groß zu denken
und unser Produkt immer weiter zu verbessern. Da geht es zur Sache. Unser Unternehmen wurde
2015 gegründet und ist seither zu einem Team von starken 21 Mitarbeiter herangewachsen.
Was machen die eigentlich? Was machen die? Ich muss jetzt erstmal kurz gucken. Was genau
macht Church Tools Module? Ach, also so ein Organisationsding für Kirchen. Da kann man
dann zum Beispiel irgendwie den, keine Ahnung, den Knabenchor besser planen. Es ist halt
so eine, wie heißt das so eine, wie nennt sich diese? Vereinssoftware, ja. Ja, da gibt
es noch so eine spezielle, so SAP für Kirchen quasi. Da gibt es noch so eine spezielle,
spezielle Tool Kategorie. Aber eins muss ich hier mal positiver vorheben. Das sieht
gar nicht so web 0.50 aus. ERP, genau. Eigentlich ist es wirklich schlau sowas zu machen, weil
ich denke mal, gerade Kirchen sind nur wirklich nicht der Vorreiter der Digitalisierung. Wenn
man da was fertiges anbietet, ist das erstmal nicht schlecht. Das sieht ein bisschen aus
wie Bootstrap. Bootstrap-y auf jeden Fall sieht es aus, aber könnte alles mögliche
sein. Sind das Material Design Icons? Nee, gell. Sind andere. Oder, Chet? Ja, das ist
es. Das ist nicht das Material Design Settings Icon. Okay. Der schnell wachsende Kundenstamm,
die enge Zusammenarbeit mit vielen, wir sind auf keinen Fall ein Unternehmen, das stehen
bleibt und sich mit all dem zufrieden gibt. Na ja, gut, für Gottes Reich kann man schon
mal sich Mühe geben. Um uns weiterzuentwickeln und für die Zukunft noch besser aufgestellt
zu sein, möchten wir unser Team im Bereich Systemadministration ausbauen. Alles klar.
Church Tools, die brauchen. Rocket Chat, GitLab, Wordpress. Das ist doch mal was hier. Gut,
mein Wordpress ist vielleicht ein bisschen pains-champig, aber Rocket Chat und GitLab,
das klingt ja schon mal, als wissen die, was sie da treiben. Ja, Patrick stimmt schon.
Das würde ich auf jeden Fall auch in Lebenslauf schreiben, wenn ich da mal gewesen wäre. Hallo,
das finde ich gut. Du behältst regelmäßige Updates von Betriebssystemen und Anwendungen.
Ja gut, jetzt wäre es natürlich gut zu wissen, ob es Windows oder Linux ist. Da sollte man
sich da vielleicht noch hinschreiben. Aber wahrscheinlich ist es beides. Was ist GitLab?
Kenne nur GitHub. GitLab ist eine quasi eine Self-hostbare Alternative. Allerdings haben
die auch das Ganze als Service. Das gibt es quasi einmal als GitHub-Alternative und einmal
als Self-hosted GitHub-Alternative. Das ist gar nicht schlecht. Das hatte ich auch bei
uns eine Weile auf der Arbeit im Einsatz, bis ich es nicht mehr benutzen durfte, weil
wir Bitbucket verwenden müssen. Ich hatte ja einen GitLab bei uns lokal installiert und
es lief eigentlich ganz gut. Irgendwann hat dann einer zu mir gesagt, darfst du nicht
mehr machen, wir brauchen Bitbucket. Und jetzt haben wir das Problem, Bitbucket soll umgeschaltet
werden auf die Cloud und die Cloud-Lösung. Braucht sich Java-Plugins dafür, um das zu
machen, was ich mit GitLab damals schon längst gebaut hatte. Aber gut, was willst du machen?
Die wollen halt extra Geld ausgeben, da kann man nichts machen. Was auch witzig ist, GitLab
war eine ganze Zeit auf GitHub gehostet. Weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so ist. Nicht mehr
so, oder? Es ist nicht mehr gehostet, ah doch. Nee. Nee. GitLab ist mittlerweile nicht mehr
auf GitHub gehostet. Interessant. Okay, zurück zu Gottes Reich. Also hier fände ich es ganz
interessant, wenn man dabei schreiben würde, welche Betriebssysteme es wären. Warum haben
die kein eigenes GitHub von Church Tools? Ja, wie könnte man das dann dann nennen?
TempleOS. Naja, vom Namen her wird es passen, aber nutzen kannst du das ja auch nicht. Holyhub,
das finde ich gut. Git-Helfen. Pragerhub. Haha, Pragerhub. Ja. Wahrscheinlich ist es
Windows und Linux. Okay. Bei neuen Anforderungen konzipierst du eine Lösung und passt die
Infrastruktur auf die neue Anforderung an. Okay. Hacker haben es schwer, weil du unsere
Server absichterst, sicherst. Solange es nicht Java ist, was drauf läuft. Ausfallsicherheit
liegt dir am Herzen und können wir dich auf dich zählen. Na, das ist doch vollkommen im
Rahmen alles hier. Deine Umsetzung und die Prozesse hältst du schriftlich fest, dass
Team an deinem Wissenstand teilhaben soll. Man soll auch noch was dokumentieren hier.
Ja. Ja, Quai. Schick, schick her. Ich mein, eigentlich muss man nichts dokumentieren,
weil das vom ersten... Ich mein, wenn es keine Bugs gibt, brauchst du keine Doku. Quasi
die zehn Geburte. Die zehn Geburte. Die zehn Prozesse haben die dann. Die zehn Prozesse.
Job-Tools. Job-Teaser. Internship. Oh, das klingt so nach unbezahlt, oder? Aber wir
gucken uns das andere erstmal kurz fertig an. Dein Profil. Findest du dich hier wieder?
Durch dein Informatik... Leute, nervt euch das mit meinem Geschmatze und dem Bonbon oder
ist das okay? Durch dein Informatikwirtschaftsinformatikstudium oder eine vergleichbare Ausbildung hast du
ein bereit aufgestelltes IT-Knowhow. Du hast Erfahrung mit Linux-Servern, Administrationen,
Netzwerken, VLANs, VPNH, Failover, DNS. Okay, da hat man einfach mal random alles Mögliche
reingeschrieben, was dich so wirklich viel da miteinander zu tun hat, außer dass man
es vielleicht grob im Bereich Netzwerk verorten könnte. Geht schon. Du kennst dich mit Surfer
Automatis... Ansible. Guck mal hier. Gottes Reich wird gemanagt mit Ansible. Das finde
ich cool. Ansible ist, wenn ihr mich fragt, die beste dieser ganzen Lösungen, die es
da so gibt für Surfer Automatisierung. Und was hast du denn alles? Von Puppet bis Chef
bis Zollstack, was nicht alles gibt. Hält noch... CF Engine war früher voll angesagt.
Hatte jemand mal die große Ehre, mit CF Engine arbeiten zu dürfen? Das waren so Zeiten,
wo man auch Nagios noch zum Monitoring verwendet hat. CF Engine. CF Engine hat eine nicht
ganz so schöne Syntax. Du hast immer noch Nagios verwendet. Ja, kann man ja auch machen.
Das sieht anders aus, als ich es in Erinnerung habe. So, aber da finde ich schon mal gut,
dass die Ansible verwenden. Richtig nice. Postgres, MySQL, PAP, Nginx, HAProxy, Proxmox.
Eine, sagen wir mal so, bis auf Proxmox, eine relativ traditionelle Kombination. Warum
man zwei Datenbanken braucht, weiß ich nicht. Aber gut, historisch. Du bist engagiert, kreativ,
die Kundenorientierung liegt dir am Herzen, natürlich. Meine Kundenorientierung, da geht
kaum was drüber. Okay. Also alles andere könnte ich ja noch mich sehen, ja. Das ist
alles in Ordnung. Und ob ich jetzt ganz ehrlich, ich sage euch jetzt mal, wie es ist. Ich bin
einer der ungläubigsten Leute, die es wahrscheinlich gibt. Aber ob ich jetzt irgendwelchen Banken
in Frankfurt helfe, alten Omas Versicherungen zu verkaufen, die sie nicht brauchen, oder
ob ich irgendwelchen Kirchengemeinden helfe, ihre Schafe zu besser zu managen, macht doch
unterm Strich für mich keinen Unterschied. Dann ist das hier wahrscheinlich die noch,
soll ich sagen, die noch bessere Sache. Aber ich arbeite halt nicht aktiv in meiner Kirchengemeinde
vor Ort mit. Aber ich bin noch, ich bin nicht ausgetreten. Ach so, okay. Ich bin nie ausgetreten
aus der Kirche, obwohl ich da bestimmt schon noch 25 Jahre nicht mehr war. Ich war 25
Jahre nicht mehr in der Kirche. Aber ich bezahle Kirchensteuer. Tja, fragt mich nicht warum.
Prager. Ich glaube eh, du warst mit eins das letzte Mal in der Kirche. Nee, ich war mit.
Wann macht man Kommunion? Mit 8 oder so? Mit 10? Danach war ich nie wieder in der Kirche.
Also habe ich noch mitgemacht, aber danach war ich nie wieder da. Na doch Beerdigung,
aber Beerdigung war nicht in der Kirche, es war im Friedhof. Erfirmung habe ich auch nicht
mehr gemacht. Ich habe, Leute wisst ihr was der einzige Grund war, warum ich Kommunion
überhaupt mitgemacht habe damals? Der einzige Grund war, ohne Scheiß, Stonks. Einfach nur
Stonks. Heutzutage was? Bei der Jugendfeier, ich weiß gar nicht was eine Jugendfeier ist.
Ich habe nur Kommunion gemacht. Firmung habe ich nicht mehr gemacht. Wie viel sollte man
als IT Systemkaufmann bekommen? Das kommt immer ganz entscheidend, also ich habe keine
Ahnung davon, aber das kommt ganz entscheidend von der Region ab. Und auch ein bisschen von
der Branche wo du hingehst, aber die Region ist da schon ziemlich entscheidend.
Ja, ich bezahle Kirchensteuer.
Obwohl ich so mit Glaubenssachen überhaupt nichts am Hut habe, ich kann mich noch daran
erinnern. Ich habe mal versucht einen von meinen Abonnenten zum Islam zu bekehren. Der
hat sich wirklich Gedanken um mich gemacht, da habe ich mal, das war noch, weiß ich noch,
das war als ich relativ neu auf YouTube war, das muss so 2010, 2011 war das, das muss sein
wo ich schon ein bisschen bekannt auf YouTube war, aber noch relativ frisch und dann hat
mir irgendwie einer eine Mail geschrieben, so nach dem Motto, oder PN war das glaube
ich noch damals auf YouTube, er macht sich Sorgen um mich und ich soll mir doch mal überlegen,
was mal später passiert. Nein, nicht Pierre Vogel, für den Fall, wer weiß, damals vielleicht
war es ja Pierre Vogel himself, keine Ahnung. Und ich soll mir doch mal Gedanken machen,
so quasi, was weiß ich, was nach dem Tod passiert oder so, ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau was
er geschrieben hat. Und deswegen möchte er mir jetzt so die einschwache Religion erzählen.
Da habe ich dann abgewunken, habe gesagt ey, ich habe mit Glaubensfragen nichts am Hut,
egal mit was du mich bekehren willst, sei es mit Jesus, mit Allah, mit Buddha, mit frag
mich nicht, da kommst du bei mir nicht weit. Was gibt es denn sonst noch, mit Außerirdischen
die dich abholen wenn die Welt untergeht oder mit irgendwelchen anderen Dingern.
Also, das ist egal, das schockt mich alles nicht. Christian Lindner vielleicht, ja. Gibt
es den Hetzner Code noch? Ja, Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im Chat bis zum 31.12. Oh Mist, ich
muss mal meine Mails gucken, das habe ich ganz vergessen. Ich wollte Hetzner eine Zusammenfassung
schicken von YouTube Videos und Streams die ich letztes Jahr gemacht habe, das habe ich
ganz vergessen. Mal gucken, ich hoffe sie haben es ja nicht beschwert. Kann immer passieren.
Ich habe nur eine Anfrage bekommen für Dying Light. Taugt das Leute Dying Light? Das geht
glaube ich, ja du musst da bis zum 31 einlösen. Das ist das zweite Bonbon, ne das dritte.
Chat, wie ist Dying Light? Ich sehe gerade ich habe in den Mails eine Anfrage bekommen
für Dying Light. Coming Up Campaign. Dying Light. 2. 2. Awareness for Game. Oh die wollen
schon im Januar starten. Also was soll ich denn machen? One Integrated Video Placement
soll ich machen. Und links setzen. Oh ich soll reacten auf den Trailer. Alles klar. Na gut
wenn die mir jetzt 2000 Euro für geben, reacte ich auch 30 Sekunden auf den Trailer. Das
ist kein Problem. Das können wir gerne machen. Da muss ich mal antworten. Ne das gucke ich
mir nicht an. Also wenn ich die Chance habe dafür Geld abzugreifen, dann mache ich das
jetzt bestimmt nicht umsonst im Stream. Also wenn die mir da ordentlich Kohle für bezahlen,
rate ich auch auf den Trailer. Also wir haben uns Gottesreich angeguckt. Ich muss sagen
ich finde das an sich tatsächlich recht ansprechend kann man jetzt nicht sagen, aber durchaus
in Ordnung ja. Ich glaube es gibt halt wenige. Also ich glaube in meinem Berufszweig sind
die Leute glaube ich noch ungläubiger als sonst. Ich vermute. Ich glaube ja. Also wenn
ich an einen glaube, dann ist es. Ich finde das Emote nicht Leute ich habe zu viele Emotes.
Der findet Gaben zuerst. Da ist er. Wobei der eigentlich auch schon uns ziemlich hängen
gelassen hat mit Half Life 3. So eigentlich passt das nicht wirklich. Du kannst dich hier
nur teilweise wiederfinden. Macht nicht. Wir lernen dich trotzdem gerne kennen und finden
gemeinsam heraus wie du deine Gaben bei Church Tools einbringen kannst. Das ist uns wichtig.
Der Glaube an Jesus verbindet uns. Der Glaube an Jesus verbindet uns und spielt auch im Arbeitsalltag
eine wichtige Rolle. Wird dann morgens um 10 erstmal beim Frühstück. Eine Runde danke
Herr für deine Gaben. Ich meine warum nicht. Ich denke in dem Fall wenn man sich mit dieser
Sache wirklich identifizieren kann ist das doch gar nicht mal so übel. Ich kriege dann
30 Minuten zusätzliche Zeit zum beten. Wir beten im Daily Scrum. Da machen wir nicht
Daily Stand Up. Da machen wir Daily Pray. Vielleicht hat man auch Glück und kann direkt morgens
erstmal beichten. Der Sprint zum Beichtstuhl. Genau. Beichten Speedrun. Und wenn du da eine
Sicherheitslücke machst ist das kein Problem. Dann wird erstmal kurz zu Gottes Reich geprayt
und dann hast du Glück. Dann trifft es alle außer dich. Die müssen den Holy See programmieren.
Okay. Offenheit, Freundlichkeit, Ehrlichkeit und Geduld sind unheimlich im Umgang mit einer
Sonne auch deine Grundeigenschaften gehören. Im Team mit den unterschiedlichsten Menschen
zusammen ist eine enorme Bereiche bereit. Die Freunde durch unsere Entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit
bleibt die Arbeit immer kurzweilig und ist es wichtig, dass du bereit bist konstant
Neues zu lernen. Ich habe kein Problem. Einfach ein bisschen beten dabei. 4 oder 5 Tage genau
richtig für mich. Okay. Das ist gut. Das finde ich richtig gut, dass sie das standardmäßig
schon drin haben. Du kannst dort arbeiten oder im Homeoffice, weil ich würde mich da
garantiert nicht bewerben, weil ich keinen Bock hatte, er hätte irgendwie, was soll
ich in Karlsruhe? Das ist viel zu weit weg. Wie weit ist Karlsruhe weg? Bestimmt 2-3 Stunden,
oder? Aber trotzdem zu weit. Kannst ja nicht jeden Tag eine Stunde ICE fahren, weil davon
abgesehen ist. Kommt ja überhaupt nicht pünktlich. Wertschätzung eine angenehme Arbeitsatmosphäre,
das könnte ich mir dort wirklich vorstellen. Die sind alle so ausgeglichen, weil sie Prege
machen. Dich erwarten die nettesten Kunden. Da habe ich meine Zweifel. Es gibt so gut
wie keine netten Kunden. Ist ja auch klar, meistens hast du was mit denen zu tun, wenn
was kaputt ist. Ein bisschen abgefuckt, weil sie Geld bezahlen für was, was nicht funktioniert.
Hoodie, Flipflops, Anzug. Du darfst gerne legere zur Arbeit kommen. Ich meine Hoodie
okay, aber Flipflops müssen doch nicht wirklich sein. Zum Thema Flipflops gab es bei uns
auch eine lustige Geschichte. Bei uns ist auch mal irgendjemand im Sommer mit Flipflops
durch Haus gelaufen und es hat dann irgendein Anzug Stonksmann gesehen aus einem Obergeschoss
und hat danach eine E-Mail losgeschickt, dass wir auf angemessene Bekleidung achten sollen.
Aber der Witz war, danach kann der Betriebsrat anstarten, hat gemeint es gibt aber bei uns
keine Arbeitsregelung. Die Begründung war aber auch geil. Wisst ihr was die Begründung
war, warum wir nach Möglichkeit Anzug anziehen sollten? Die Begründung war ja, der Außendienst
bei uns repräsentiert uns ja auch im Anzug. Was ist das für eine bescheuerte Begründung
gewesen? Wenn ich im Außendienst arbeite, den ganzen Tag, welchen Omas vielleicht was
verkaufen muss, was sie nicht haben wollen. Und dafür im Anzug rumrennen muss, ok, aber
das muss ich doch nicht, wenn ich mich um irgendwelche Server kümmere oder Software
programmiere für den Laden. xSlimBeats. Dankeschön für den Sub. Aha, betriebliche
Altersvorsorge lohnt sich eigentlich fast immer, wenn der Arbeitgeber was dabei bezahlt,
wobei 30% ein bisschen wenig ist. Bei mir sind es 50%, sonst hätte ich das wahrscheinlich
auch nicht gemacht. Technische Ausstattung auf aktuellstem Stand. Heißt? Das finde ich
gut, dass sie das schreiben. Du kannst quasi weichten gehen bei ihnen, kannst sagen, mein
feiler Arbeitgeber suckt. Ich würde gern zu euch. Mich würde jetzt ja interessieren,
was die so bezahlen. Onboarding. Schnell auf Flughöhe kommen. Ok, das da hat irgendjemand
anderes geschrieben als diesen Text. Das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche zwei Schreibstile.
Das hier ist so ein typischer, super agiler Jungmanager Satz. Als neues Teammitglied im
Team möchtest du schnell auf Flughöhe kommen. Niemand der normal redet würde so einen Satz
aussprechen. Na ja. Klingt das gut. Bei der Frau Glaser können wir uns bewerben. Church
Tools Innovation in Karlsruhe. Leider hat man absolut keine Ahnung. Komm wir gucken
mal kurz, was Church Tools für Bewertungen hat. Äh, auf was? Was gibt's denn da so?
Leute, sagt mir mal so eine Arbeitgeberbewertungsplattform, welche taugt denn da? Kuhnunu. Xing. Clastore
an die, wo die Dice Mitarbeiter geschrieben haben, wie kacke Dice ist. Anscheinend gibt's
die nicht da. Aber reicht es nicht zu wissen, dass man seiner Gemeinde und Gott dient?
Das müsste eigentlich reichen. Warum sollte man dafür Geld nehmen? Für Gottes Reich kann
man auch mal umsonst arbeiten. Was haben sie sonst noch zu bieten? Ja, das haben wir uns
eingeguckt. Junges Christliches Unternehmen. Ich will noch mal kurz gucken, was die bei...
Ach guck mal, das sieht jetzt komplett anders aus. Webseiten. Ein hochmotiviertes Team von
Christen. Okay, ich muss sagen, das ist für mich jetzt kein wirklich geiler Vorteil. Aber
okay, ich finde es insofern ja gut, dass man sich dafür mit internifiziert. Du musst dir
unbedingt dieses Stellenwerbungsvideo anschauen. Oh Gott, Grinch. Grinch, ich sehe es jetzt
schon. Gringe. Hey, das, was das da oben in der Uhr ist, ist das eine MongoDB Object oder
eine MD5-Summe? Das sieht aus wie... Ach nee, das ist eine MD5. Ich dachte erst, es ist
eine Shard 250 von der Länge her. Es ist wahrscheinlich eine MD5-Summe, ja. Ja, das
ist bitte ein Wordpress-Sign. Das wird irgendein Wordpress-Sign, weil die haben ja auch gesagt,
die suchen Leute für Wordpress. Wahrscheinlich irgendeine Object-ID, ja. Durchaus möglich.
Guck mal, nach WP-Admin. Exist-Denied. Heißt das jetzt, das gibt's oder das gibt's nicht?
Ach nee, Exist-Denied. Was auch immer. Backend-Entwicklerin. Das hatten wir ja, PHP, Frontend. Clean Code
und Unit-Test-Try-And-Solid sind keine Fremdwörter für dich. Also, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
mittlerweile gibt es so viele krassen, agilen Frameworks. Ich blicke da nicht mal durch.
Ich meine, das erste nicht. Das hat mit agilen Frameworks nichts zu tun. Das ist eine MongoDB-ID,
aber Solid, bin ich mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr so sicher. Ist das nicht Solid
Single-Responsibility? Keine Ahnung. Ja, Fest. Super. Single. Also. Zeig mal her. Solid.
Single-Responsibility. Open-Close. Liskov-Substitution-Prinzip. Ah, Obvious, Obvious. Alles klar. Das Liskov-Substitution
Principle. Das beachte ich eh bei meiner Software, da muss ich nicht jetzt explizit hier draufgucken.
Interface-Segregation-Prinzip. Dependency-Inversion-Prinzip. Aha. Alles klar. Das ist Don't Repeat Yourself,
glaube ich. Dafür steht Try. Gut. Clean-Code-Unit-Test kann man sich ja noch was drunter vorstellen.
Okay. Church-Tools. Nice. Also, was sollte ich mir als nächstes angucken? Internship.
Internship klingt schon mal nach unbezahlt. Das ist ja quasi Praktikum sowas in der Richtung.
Ja. Bei IBM Deutschland. Rechio Niedersachsen. Okay, Niedersachsen. Weil ich hätte jetzt
gesagt Frankfurt, hätte ich noch ein bisschen mehr Plan gehabt. Ich habe davon echt, also
gerade was kaufmännische Sachen angeht, wirklich keinen Plan. Du kannst mal bei Heise gucken,
die hatten erst letztens wieder irgendeine Gehaltsumfrage und im Zweifelsfall beim letzten
Stack-Overflow-Gehaltsding. Aber Heise hatte letztens wieder irgendeine Gehaltsumfrage.
Ist nicht unbezahlt. Okay. Also, was wollen die dann haben? IBM DB2 vor ZOS. Aber das
ist halt auch schon der Brauchste. Eigentlich bräuchten die da mal mindestens diese Kirchensoftware,
weil da musste auch viel beten für. Also, DB2 auf Host quasi auf Z-Series, IBM Großrechner.
Wobei das mittlerweile wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil auch über Cloud-Geschichten bei IBM
läuft, könnte ich mir vorstellen. Also, bla bla bla. Cloud-Pack. Noch nie gehört. Die
Musik vorbei. Okay. DB2-Data-Gate-CLI. Was ist das für ein Gelaber? Was ist das für
eine Stellenanzeige? DB2-Data-Gate-CLI-Allows-User-Friendly-Installation-of-IBMs-Data-and-AI-Plattform.
Ja, schön. Was hat das mit mir zu tun? Cloud-Pack-for-Data-Plattform-Services-Collecting-Organizing-Analysing-Infusing-Data-One-Click-Deployment-Red Hat-Open-Shift-IBM-Cloud. Okay. Was hat das mit mir zu tun? GitHub. Ja. Ah, ja. Hier.
Your task will be to improve and extend CLI's. Als Praktikant? Ist das eine Arbeit für einen
Praktikant? Eigentlich nicht, oder? Ich meine, die wollen irgendeinen Junior-Entwickler haben
eigentlich, oder? Das ist doch keine Arbeit für einen Praktikant. Ach, ist das für Studenten?
Ist das für Studenten, die irgendwie praktisch, praktische Erfahrungen sammeln müssen oder
sowas? Ja, gut. Dann kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das in Ordnung ist. Okay.
Multicultural. Okay. Blah, blah, blah, blah. Deep knowledge. Blah, blah, blah, blah. System-Administration-of-a-code-deploy. Ja, was denn jetzt? Ich denke,
man kümmert sich um die Entwicklung des CLI-Tools. Das wirkt fast so, als steht das hier in jeder
Anzeige von denen drin und das hier ist jetzt spezifisch. Benefits for Supervisors. Was?
Ach so, mit deinen Aufsehern quasi. Wie übersetzt? Was ist die korrekte Übersetzung für Supervisor?
Also wirklich Aufpasser und Aufseher, übergeordnete Chefs, halt Betreuer. Ja, sowas. Mentor. Ja,
sowas in der Richtung. Ja, genau. Okay. Interested and available für drei bis, ach so drei
bis sechs Monate. Okay. Please read on check. Ja, wann man darf oder was die Anforderungen
sind, damit man sich dafür eignet oder gültig ist. Motivation-Letter. Okay, Motivation-Letter,
das ist im Prinzip sowas wie wahrscheinlich normales Anschreiben halt. Da musst du nicht
erzählen und denen was vorlügen. Jawoll, ich hab schon immer seit ich klein bin davon
geträumt bei IBM zu arbeiten oder so ein Blödsinn. Hey Max, kannst du dich erinnern? Habt ihr
vor vielen Jahren zwei Patronen geschickt? Dunkel, dunkel. Kann ich mich dran erinnern?
Ja. Ich kann mich dunkel dran erinnern. Hab ich auch glaube ich noch irgendwo, ja? Ganz
dunkel. Hab ich aber glaube ich seit dem Umzug 2013 nicht mehr gesehen, die sind wahrscheinlich
in irgendeiner Kiste drin. Aber ja, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern. Schön, dass du den
dich hierher gefunden hast. Okay, Required Technical Professional Expertise. Knowledge of
Jason and Rest. Strong, Strong Pison Skills brauchste. Genau, 50, 50. Ja, ja, da kann
ich mich noch dran erinnern. Wir brauchen Strong Pison Skills. Strong. Und Shit müssen
wir kennen. C1. Was ist C1? Englisch C1, ist das gut oder? Advanced. Alles kein Problem.
In my home country Baden-Württemberg we say we are all sitting in one boat. Also wenn
so einer zum EU Kommissar schafft, dann komme ich damit auch weiter. Professional Expertise,
Bachelor Degree. So und was gibt es für Geld? Seller, Salarien, was muss ich denn suchen,
dass ich finde, was ist? Steht das oder steht das? Irgendwas 3000, 1,3 K gibt es. Ja, ich
denke, das kann man schon machen. Das liegt sich jetzt gar nicht so schlecht, wenn man
sich dafür interessiert. 1,2 gibt es. Oh, this job is no longer available. Ja, wahrscheinlich
weil Jaguar in den Job hat, oder? Hast du den schon gekriegt? Siehste, deswegen ist
er not available. Ok, C1 ist angeblich voll krass, alles klar. Bei mir ist es mit Englisch
immer so eine Sache. Ich bin das halt null gewöhnt. Ich kann mittlerweile, wenn es jetzt
nicht gerade Shakespeare ist oder irgendwie sowas, weil die meisten Deutschen auch Goethe
im Original wahrscheinlich weniger verstehen, wenn es sich gerade irgendwie so super abgedreht
ist, verstehe ich eigentlich alles easy mittlerweile. Ich kann halt nicht gut Englisch reden, weil
ich keine Übung habe. Und ich merke das immer, wenn mal irgendwas ist, zum Beispiel ein Event,
wie die Games kommen, dann tue ich mir den ersten Tag immer übelst schwer, aber danach
geht es eigentlich. Stream auf Englisch, oh ne, das will ich euch nicht antun. Also ich
sage nicht, dass es irgendwie auf dem Level hier wäre oder so, ich habe keine Ahnung,
was das bedeutet. Aber ich komme da eigentlich ganz klar, wir haben schon öfters auch mal
Mitarbeiter gehabt, englische Muttersprachler, mit denen konnte ich dann auch zeitweise auf
Englisch labern und habe gesagt, lass mal ausprobieren, ob das so geht. Das funktioniert,
aber mir fehlt einfach die Übung. Obwohl ich, ich kenne die meisten Wörter, weil wenn
ich sie lese, verstehe ich sie und weiß, was sie heißen, aber mir fallen die Wörter,
wenn ich selbst drauf kommen muss, immer nicht ein. We want you. Ja, das ist von 2017. We
want you. 2017, das ist ja schon ewig her. Battle Eye, benutzt das überhaupt noch jemand?
Gold Standard Anti-Cheat. Basic Knowledge of X86 Assembler, easy, easy, easy. Das ist
was für ein Patrick hier. Das ist doch so mit Low-Level Shit. C++, ah, gehste weg.
Jetzt wird es aber abgedreht hier. Also ganz ehrlich, dann mache ich lieber Assembler,
bevor ich C++ mache. Aber das ist tatsächlich ohne Scheiß, wenn du Anti-Cheat Software
basteln willst, da ist das durchaus legitim alles hier. Good English Skills. Aha, ist
doch vollkommen in Ordnung, was sie hier fordern für Anti-Cheat Software. So, was sollten wir
jetzt? Das sollte ich mir auch noch angucken. IT-Arbeitgeber, wo sind wir hier? Bei der Bundesbank.
Sind die auch in Frankfurt? Hessische Landesbank ist in Frankfurt. Sind die auch in Frankfurt?
Wo ist hier? Oh, die Gebärden, in Gebärdensprache brauche ich das unbedingt. Wo ist hier Impressum?
Wo ist das Impressum? Da hier Impressum. Wo ist das? Muss ich kurz gucken. Moment, wo
ist das? Ah, das ist weiter außerhalb. Hier unten ist der Hauptbahnhof irgendwo. Irgendwo
hier ist der Hauptbahnhof. Da ist der Hauptbahnhof. Okay, das ist ein bisschen weg. Das ist tatsächlich
ein Stückchen weg. Die sind nicht bei uns in der Ecke. Okay, also, was soll ich mir
da angucken? Alter, das Video ist cringe. Okay, oh Gott, das Video ist bestimmt richtig cringe.
Okay, jetzt wird es Pains Champ. Aber diese Sache gibt es bei uns auch oftmals in Kombination,
dass du irgendwelche Anzugleute hast und irgendjemand, der nicht in ihrer Welt konform aussieht,
steigt in den Fahrstuhl. Da wird auch komisch gekockt. Der arbeitet bestimmt im First Level
oder so. Was haben die gesagt? Was wird gelästert? Ja, aber er sorgt dafür, dass euer Shit geht.
User Provisioning. Ah, okay. Windows Active Directory, zweimal klicken oder so. Hackermans.
Was ist? Ist das Final Fantasy Tactics oder was spielt der da? Christ. Komm mal, Prager
ist auch wieder am Start. Der sollte sich mal bei den anderen bewerben. Aber RGB-Beleuchtung
drum herum. Ah, Christoph, Anwendungsentwickler. Warum steht ein Anwendungsentwickler mit dem
Notebook aufgeklappt im Rechenzentrum? Das ist ja schon mal komplett verkehrt herum.
Das hat mit der Realität nichts zu tun. Was macht der denn da? Was hat er da zu suchen?
Der darf da wahrscheinlich gar nicht rein in Wirklichkeit. Oh nein, please. Cringe.
Veins Champ. Veins Champ, nein. Hört mal auf. Ah, Projektlein. Ich dachte eigentlich
jetzt Personalabteilung oder so. Übertreibt es halt mal mit der Musik. Ah, ein Holderrecke.
Security Cloud Computing. Alles klar. Upcycle. Ein was? Was ist denn ein Upcycler? So Mountain
Bike kenne ich, aber... Moment. Upcycler. Ach du Scheiße, da wäre ich ja im Leben nicht
drauf gekommen. Man macht aus kaputten Dingern wieder neue. Upcycler. Es ist ja irgendwann
ist auch mal gut, oder? Kommunikationstechnik. Last Level. Moment. Sowas gibt es?
Was ist denn das? Sowas wie Third Level oder was? Last Level Support. Ist das eigentlich
First Level und man möchte den Leuten quasi einreden? Nein, nein, nein, nein. Ihr seid
nicht First Level. Wir sind Last Level. Quasi eins vor unendlich Support. Last Level.
Erst mal Upcyclen. Bewerb dich. Okay. Ah ne, es geht noch weiter. Das ist der Bundespark-Präsident.
Aha. Okay, jetzt wollen sie uns damit sagen, dass es ja auch ein ganz cooler Typ, weil
er Turnschuhe an hat. Das ist ja so ein cooler Chef, der hat Turnschuhe an. Hey Fellow Kids.
Genau. Journey to Cloud. Die haben schon mal nicht Englisch C1. So, Aufgaben, Bundespark,
Karriere. Okay. Jobbörse. Zeit mal her. Was haben die zu bieten? Was? Eben war es noch
da? Ah, das ist ein anderes Video, Zack. Ja, da sind wir. Kann man da ein Angebot für
IT-Fachkräfte. Filter. Was haben wir hier zu bieten? Cloud Services Engineer. Männlich
weiß Deutsch. Da sind wir mal wieder. IT Trainees. Mitarbeiterinnen für das Projekt
EUROSYSTEM. Collateral Management System. ECMS. Alles klar. Software Engineers. Sprachtechnologin-Computerlingu-. Okay,
ich hab legit keine Ahnung, was man da macht. Was macht man denn als Sprachtechnologin-Computerlinguist?
Was macht man als Computerlinguist? Man übersetzt Software? Ah. Übersetzer. Okay. Cloud Service
Services. Schwerpunkt Cloud Application Services. Oder Cloud Management Services. Gesucht werden
für unseren Bereich. Blah, blah, blah, blah. Blah, blah, blah. Auf Vorlesen. Zack, das muss
ich testen, ob das ordentlich funktioniert. Sie arbeiten gerne eigenverantwortlich. Das
ist gerade mal schlechter Text-to-Speech von denen. Gesucht werden für unseren Bereich
Informationstechnik. Was meint ihr, worüber die das laufen lassen haben? Ist das Amazon?
Technologie-Klammer auf. Können wir nachgucken? Gucken wir einfach, wo die Requests hingehen.
Warum ist das auf iPad eingestellt? Ah. Moment, wie mach ich das wieder auf Fullscreen?
Can't wait. Ah, hier. Ja. Okay, gucken wir mal, worüber das geht. Gesucht werden für
unseren Bereich Informations-Technologie-Klammer auf. Ja. Air-Send. Read Speaker Core. Air-Send.
Ich hab immer eine Ahnung, was das ist. Read Speaker Core JS. Ah, Read Speaker. Der Service
heißt so Read Speaker. Okay, hab ich ja nie gehört. Wozu braucht man das? Naja, zum Beispiel
für Leute, die Sehbehinderung haben oder so. Ich find das gut, dass die das haben. Also
was haben die denn hier so am Start? Also. Journey to Cloud. Pass. Okay, also ihre Aufgaben.
Okay, hybride Cloud-Umgebung, jetzt mal auf Deutsch übersetzt. Wir haben eigentlich alles
noch lokal stehen, wollen aber sagen, wir machen ganz viel Cloud. Also sagen wir jetzt
einfach, unser lokale Geschiss ist eine Hybrid-Cloud, damit sich das besser anhört. Und dann nehmen
wir ein paar Services, die easy in die Cloud zu packen sind und ziehen sie einfach in
ein paar Cloud-VMS um. Und dann haben wir ein paar VMs in Azure stehen oder bei Amazon
und können sagen, Alter, unsere Cloud-Umgebung, die ist so toll. Sie haben ja einen DNS-Server
in der Cloud. Ja, das war es wahrscheinlich. Okay. Dabei übernehmen sie als Teil des Teams.
Also darf man Legacy migrieren. Da kannst du bei Banken generell davon ausgehen. Banken
bestehen. Banken, unsere aktuelle Banken-Infrastruktur läuft auf Legacy. Also, dass ihr überhaupt
euer Geld aus dem Automat bekommt, ist Legacy-Technologie. So wie Scoreboards in Battlefield. Ungefähr
so auf gleicher Ebene. Benutzt ihr eigentlich AWS oder ja, wir benutzen Terraform. Wir benutzen
kein AWS auf der Arbeit. Wir haben alles bei Azure. Obwohl ich vorgeschlagen habe, wir
können, das ist kein Witz, wir könnten unseren Storage doch bei Hetzner hinlegen. Ich besorge
uns auch einen 20-Euro-Startgutschein. Habe ich vorgeschlagen auf der Arbeit, wollte keiner.
Wenn ihr euch auch einen 20-Euro-Startgutschein sichern wollt, Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im
Chat, könnt ihr noch einlösen bis zum 31.12. Und das Guthaben müsst, solltet ihr eigentlich
danach auch behalten. Da könnt ihr beispielsweise einen Triple-Core-Server fast drei Monate
von laufen lassen. Spielst du heute noch Battlefield? Nein. Journey to Cloud ist ein Trademark.
Aha. Okay. Das Engineering von neuen Services. Okay, das kann alles bedeuten. Mal gucken,
wie das ausspricht. Das Engineering von neuen Services. Ganz gut. Das kann ja alles
bedeuten. Das ist einfach komplett Wildcard. Sternchen. Die hätten einfach auch Sternchen
hinschreiben können. Das Engineering von neuen Services. Die hätten eigentlich Punkt-Sternchen
als Regex hinschreiben können. Das ist einfach eine... beinhaltet alles und nichts. Leute,
League-Prain-Frage an den Chat. Was ist der Unterschied in Regex zwischen Punkt-Sternchen
und Punkt-Plus? Regex, MonkaW. Wer weiß es? Aha. Bei Plus mindestens ein Zeichen. Richtig,
ich sehe, die Prime-Subs haben ihre Wirkung entfaltet, Chat. Ist das einer der unangekündigten
Tests? Ja. Wer es nicht weiß, muss Prime-Subs sponsoren. Für mehr IQ, dass er es weiß.
Ja, das ist richtig, Chat. Regex, Punkt-Sternchen und Punkt-Plus, der Unterschied ist, Lim-Gedamm.
Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub. Der Unterschied ist, das hier matcht auch auf nichts, weil
also Punkt ist in dem Fall immer ein beliebiges Zeichen, aber Sternchen bedeutet in dem Fall
ein beliebiges Zeichen, einmal oder beliebig oft. Und beliebig, also beliebig oft. Beliebig
oft bedeutet auch kein Mal. Und Plus heißt immer, das Zeichen mindestens einmal. Ja,
weiß nicht, wie ich da drauf komme. Deswegen könnte ich ein Punkt-Sternchen hier hinschreiben,
weil Punkt-Sternchen matcht in dem Fall auch, das kann alles und nichts bedeuten. Okay,
ich gebe zu, es ist schon fail, wenn man seine eigenen Sachen erklären muss, aber ich dachte,
ich dachte mir an der Stelle, das ist wichtig mal zu erwähnen. Du hast den Dienst gefunden,
wir haben den Dienst auch schon gefunden. Ach so, Stimme German Max Mail. Ernsthaft,
der Sprecher heißt Max hiervon? Die Anbindung und Konnektivität Bestehender. Ah Moment,
es geht noch weiter. Nochmal. Die Anbindung und Konnektivität Bestehender. Informationstechnologie.
Systeme. Ah. Hierfür stehen. Alles klar. In Racket habe ich nix gemacht. Ne, ein Lowbob,
das ist für den Sub. Okay, Konfiguration, Integration der erstellten Services in die
hybride Cloud. Moment, was? Die Konfiguration und Integration der erstellten Services in
die hybride Cloud? Ach so, Integration der erstellten Services in die hybride Cloud.
Okay, na dann. Anbindung und Konnektivität Bestehender IT System. Das ist das Hauptproblem
wahrscheinlich. Das ist wahrscheinlich die hauptsächliche Sache, die du machen wirst.
Hier verstehen sie im regelmäßigen Austausch mit in- und externen Expertinnen und Experten
Interesse geweckt, um ehrlich zu sein. Nicht mal ansatzweise. Hier verstehen sie Interesse
geweckt. Ihr Profil. Akkreditierter Bachelor oder gleichwertiger Studienabschluss der Informations-
vergleichbaren Spinninformationen oder vergleichbare langjährige Berufserfahrung. Okay. Sehr gute
Kenntnis, lange Erfahrung mit IT-Engineering. Idealerweise mit Erfahrung in DevOps und Microservices.
Das ist hier wie für mich gemacht, aber das soll ich mich bewerben. Idealerweise mit Erfahrung
in DevOps und Microservices. Sehr gute Kenntnisse und Erfahrung in der Planung und Bereitstellung
von Umgebung für die Entwicklung und das Testen von IT-Lösungen. So wie die Programmiersprachen.
Java. Ah gut. Weiß nicht ob aktuell Java so gut ist zu erwähnen. Java, Python oder R?
Okay. Das kriege ich alles hin, wenn es unbedingt sein muss, aber Java, Python. Genau so sieht
es aus. Java oder Python. Und wie spricht da denn R aus? Java, Python, R. R. Einfach
nur R. Java, Python, R. Java, Python, R. Java, Python, R. Alles klar. Und Entwicklungsplattform
vorzugsweise in einem der genannten Schwerpunktbereiche. Ah ja. Also ganz im Ernst, wenn es sein muss
und die gut bezahlen, mache ich auch Java. Warum nicht? Wobei ich, sag mal mal so, Bereitstellen
von Tests und IT-Lösungen zum Testen von Java, das mache ich ja jetzt auch schon. Erfahrung
mit moderner Infrastruktur und Systembereitstellungskonzepten, CI, CD-Umgebung. Ja gut, das mache ich ja
hauptsächlich gerade. Containerplattformen auch, Cloud-Modellen, okay, sowie unterstützende
Werkzeuge im Prozess sind von Vorteil. Ausgeprägte Teamfähigkeit verbunden mit einem hohen Maß
an Engagement und Eigenständigkeit zur Mitarbeit in Agilen, interdisziplinär besetzten Teams
mit starker Kundenzentrierung. Alter, diese heiße Luft, die da immer gesprochen wird.
Sehr gut, deutschen Englischkenntnisse in Wort und Schrift. Ah, guck mal, da kann man
sogar nachgucken, was sie bezahlen wollen. Neben verantwortungsvollen Aufgaben in der
Magie, attraktive Beschäftigungen, drei Schubstage, ein kostenloses Job, okay, das ist schon mal
ganz gut, attraktive Homeoffice-Möglichkeiten. Tja, diese Formulierung finde ich immer höchst
sus. Wenn die doch so krass und attraktiv sind, warum schreibt ihr sie nicht einfach
rein? Attraktive Homeoffice-Möglichkeiten, das kann auch sein, halber Tag in der Woche.
Das ist äußerst sus. Sie könnten nämlich einfach schreiben, wenn die wirklich, sag mal
so herausragende Homeoffice, könnten die wirklich schreiben, dass, was weiß ich, auch von zu Hause
möglich oder 80 Prozent von zu Hause möglich oder zu Hause möglich, außer bei irgendwas,
außer das ist im Prinzip so auch so eine Wildcard für alles. Ein Dienstlaptop, naja gut, ich muss ja
an irgendwas arbeiten, also dass ihr mir das Laptop zur Verfügung stellt, das hätte ich eigentlich
erwartet, weil meinen eigenen Rechner bringe ich bestimmt nicht mit. Das wär's noch. Leute,
die ganzen Bullshit-Anzeigen könntest du noch toppen, wenn die noch wollen, dass du
deinen eigenen Rechner mitbringst. Da wart ich noch drauf. So nach dem Motto, es wird kein Arbeitsplatz
zur Verfügung gestellt. Du musst deinen eigenen Desktop-Rechner mitbringen. Diensthandy, iPhone,
okay. Ja, das auch da übrigens, by the way, das ist der einzige Grund, warum ich ein iPhone habe,
weil ich das auch von meinem Arbeitgeber krieg. Und mittlerweile muss ich sagen, wahrscheinlich
würde ich mir sogar selbst eins holen. So, Vergütung in Anlehnung an TVI Döner Basis. Okay, 12. Okay,
Moment. So ist ja eine Bank zu einer Vermauung des Kunde mit dem Bampenverhältnis bis zu... Okay,
ich muss jetzt gucken nach TVI D12. 12. Ja gut, das ist immer die Frage, mit was du einsteigst. Du
wirst ja wahrscheinlich nicht bei 1 einsteigen, sondern das wird Verhandlungssache sein und vor
allem auch, wie viele Berufserfahrungen die dir da anrechnen oder nicht. Es ist die Frage,
in welcher Stufe man einsteigt. Das ist auf jeden Fall zu wenig. Das ist auch zu wenig.
Das ist auch zu wenig. Das ist okay. Also musst du schon mal Stufe 5 sein. Das heißt,
du musst da irgendwie schon mal 12 Jahre oder so da sein. Aber das ist bestimmt
Verhandlungssache. Das ist bestimmt Verhandlungssache. Wie hoch ist die Bankzulage? Wir wissen es nicht.
Wir wissen es nicht. Kann ja alles Mögliche bedeuten. Ich gehe davon aus, das ist ein
bisschen Verhandlungssache. Die werden bestimmt auch Spielraum haben zu sagen,
so nach dem Motto. Ja, sie haben keine Ahnung, schon 10 Jahre Erfahrung in dem Bereich. Sie
steigen in Stufe 3 ein oder so. Wie, das ist nicht Verhandlungssache. Die können doch nicht
jemand, der 15 Jahre Erfahrung in einem Gebiet haben, bei Stufe 1 einsteigen lassen und jemand,
der ein Jahr Erfahrung hat in einem Gebiet bei Stufe 1 einsteigen lassen. Und wenn das wirklich
so ist, kriegen die halt niemand. Deswegen kann es eigentlich auch nicht sein, dass es so immer noch
so ist, weil sonst kriegen die einfach keinen. Ja. Daher begrüßen wir besonders Bewerbungen
von Frauen. Ja, auf geht's Leute. Mein 1% weiblichen Viewer-Anteil. Auf geht's Leute,
Mädels, bewerbt euch. Aha. Alles klar, gut. Vielleicht kann ich das mit dem Video morgen
irgendwie verwursten, die Anzeige hier. Software-Engineers suchen sie auch noch.
Was wollen sie denn da haben? Du hast quasi bei Stufe 3 angefangen. Seht ihr Leute,
das ist Verhandlungssache. Okay, also sehr gute Kenntniserfahrung in der Anwendungsentwicklung
mit objektorientierten Programmiersprachen. Java. Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen Java
und Java Enterprise? Gibt es da einen Unterschied? Java ist doch immer die gleiche Sprache. Ich
glaube, das ist einfach nur dahinter geschrieben, weil. Okay. Soap. Alter, jemand bock auf XML?
Wer hat Bock auf XML? XML. Okay, Soap Rest Web Service. Ich gehe mal davon aus,
die Leute, die diese Stellanzeige erstellt haben, haben wieder keine Ahnung, um was es eigentlich
geht. Was ist Soap überhaupt für ein Name? Für was steht denn das überhaupt? Also ich weiß nur,
dass es irgendein Kommunikationsgeschiss ist zwischen Services in XML. Ich weiß nicht,
für was Soap steht. Soap. XML. Ihr habt ein schönes Beispiel von Soap. Ist es nicht super,
Alter? Poggers XML. Das ist so schön. 1999. Okay. Simple Object Access Protocol. Das ist
bestimmt eine Call of Duty Referenz. Genau. Simple. Rest in Alt. Ja, könnte man vielleicht
so sehen. Wobei die coolen Jungs von heute machen ja eh CraftQL. Also die Zoomer machen nur noch
CraftQL. So schräg Strichress. Ist ja geil. Schräg Strichress. So schräg Strichress. So
schräg Strichress. So schräg Strichress. Ja. So schräg Strichress. Web Services.
Was ist aus HTTP Get geworden? Ja, das ist ja Teil von Rest. Get ist ja Teil von Rest. Du hast,
lass mal gucken, ob ich es aus dem Kopf zusammenkriege. Du hast Get. Du hast Post.
Du hast Delete und du hast Patch. Nee. Was benutzt du noch mal für Rest in der Regel? Putt. Putt.
Nicht Patch. Aber Patch gibt es auch. Putt ist es. Ihr habt recht. Ja, genau. Putt, Putt, Putt.
Aber Putt ist das verbreitete. Relationale Daten beim Gänge, CID, CD Tools. Ja, Het. Het
verwendet auch keiner. Außer wir. Alle Five Hats. Five Hats United. Ist doch gar nicht kompliziert.
Ich glaube, Rest ist eines der, sag mal, wie soll ich sagen, der schlüssigsten Konzepte,
die man sich je ausgedacht hat, so kommunikationstechnisch. Du hast eine
HTTP Methode quasi für einen Teil von Rest. Ich finde, das ist wirklich sehr, sehr schlüssig alles.
Bei Soap sieht es schon wieder anders aus. Wobei, wie gesagt, die coolen Leute machen
e-CraftQL mittlerweile. Wobei man sagen muss, das eine schließt das andere ja nicht zwangsläufig
aus. Simpler ist Rest erst mal. Wenn du einfach nur, was weiß ich, kleine Sachen mal pushen musst,
zum größten Teil Gats machen, dann ist Rest simpler. Aber wenn du so Sachen hast wie verschiedene
Seiten oder Sortieren oder sowas, da ist CraftQL wirklich nice. Hast du Onlyfans? Ja, aber den
Link gibt es nur nach Prime-Subscription. So. Nein, ich habe keinen Onlyfans. Lullt. So,
was haben wir jetzt? Blablabla. Mathematisch statischer Verfahren. Oh, das ist bewiesen,
Auli Pfeifert. Ausgeprägte Fähigkeit zur Analyse, Bewertung und prägnanten Darstellung
kommt. Das ist nichts für mich. Guck mal, jetzt kriegst du sogar Entgeltgruppe 13. Das ist mehr
Big Brain. Aha. Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. Freige. Hab ich denn da noch alles auf?
Was ist kein Unterschied? Keine Ahnung. Soll ich euch mal die beste Stellenanzeige schon mal
spoilern, die ich in dem Video morgen zeigen werde? Die ist wirklich absolut top. Spoiler. Ja, die habe
ich hier irgendwo auf dem Desktop gespeichert. Fullstack Software Engineer und Lebensveränderer.
Der Name allein schon. Aber das ist nicht das. Das ist nicht das. Das hier. Das hier meine ich.
Das hier. Das ist die beste Stellenanzeige aller Zeiten, Leute. Leiterin IT und Innovation. Jetzt
passt mal auf. Das ist wirklich kaum noch zu toppen, was die hier abziehen. Blablabla. Das
müssen wir uns jetzt eigentlich gar nicht großartig durchlesen. Die üblichen Geschichten. Wobei,
doch, das lohnt sich tatsächlich sogar durchzulesen, weil allein schon das Intro ist an der Realität
vorbei. Unser Intro ist es, ständiger Technologievorreiter der Branche zu sein,
mit innovativster Hard- und Software immer die besten Ergebnisse für unseren Betrieb
rauszuholen. Okay, Blablabla. Um das möglich zu machen, befinden sich unsere Betriebe in einem
kontinuierlichen technologischen Entwicklungsoptimierungsprinz. Jetzt kommt's. Wir schrecken
auch vor kompletten Software- und Hardware-Umstellungen nicht zurück. Warum schreibt man
denn bitteschön sowas da rein? Das schreit doch schon eigentlich danach. Alter, wir können nicht
planen oder haben umgedreht. Wir haben keinen Plan, was wir machen. Was soll das dann heißen?
Das heißt einfach auf Deutsch übersetzt, wir sind permanent mit uns selbst beschäftigt,
weil wir eigentlich keinen Schimmer haben, was wir so treiben. Anders kann ich mir das,
weiß ich nicht, was... Wie viele Kalorien haben diese Bonbons eigentlich? Ich muss mal kurz,
kurz... Das muss man bestimmt nicht angeben, weil das medizinische... 18 Kilokalorien pro Bonbon hat
das, okay. Ist das viel? Referenzmenge für ein durch... Nee, das geht eigentlich. Referenzmenge
für einen durchschnittlichen Erwachsenen 2000 Kilokalorien. Dann hauscht mir da jetzt noch
eins rein, easy. IQ++, Kanetos... Kanetos, danke schön. Kann ich locker pro Tag 100 essen? Ja,
und dann nix anderes mehr. Okay, es geht aber weiter. Von dir als IT-Manager wünschen wir uns,
dass du nicht nur unsere Ansprüche sowie unsere Visionen teilst. Wie gesagt, wer Visionen hat,
der sollte vielleicht mal zu Church Tools bei den Anfragen. Das sind ja quasi Profis im
Visionen. Teilst, sondern diese noch weiterführst. Okay, jetzt kommt es. Jetzt kommt aber der Hit,
warum ich euch das zeige. Das ist der absolute Prüller, diese Anzeige. Also, wir machen das
jetzt langsam. Guck mal, wohlgemerkt, die suchen einen Leiter IT und Innovation. Leiter. Und die
erste Aufgabe ist Remote Support aller IT-Systeme, Computernetzwerke und Telefonsysteme.
Okay, weiter. Darüber hinaus, darüber hinaus sind sie...
Darüber hinaus sind sie für informationstechnische Fragen, Produkte und Dienstleistungen verantwortlich.
Ja, ja, da ist einfach mal alles dabei. Für einzelne Benutzerschulungen und
unterstützt für alle Benutzerschulen auch noch für alle Systeme der Hotels,
Netzwerkerweiterungen, Hardware und Software-Support. Das ist einfach mal alles.
Kommunikation und Koordination der Vertragspartner und IT-Dienstleister.
Na gut, das ist als Leiter normal, plus der andere Kram nicht. So, geht noch weiter,
jetzt hört nicht auf. Verwaltung der bestehenden IT-Systemstruktur, Hardware-Produkte,
Softwarelizenzen und Überprüfung der Wartungsverträge. Machst du auch als IT-Leiter,
kein Problem. Ausbau, Weiterentwicklung der Softwarestruktur. Du programmierst den Scheiß
auch noch. Controlling der IT-Kosten, auch noch, kein Problem, Controlling der IT-Kosten. So,
jetzt geht's, geht noch weiter. Verantwortlich für das reibungslose Funktionieren und die
Koordinierung der Anbieter von Guest-Internet, Property-Management-Systems, Point-of-Sale,
POS, IPTV, Telefonsystemen und anderen Softwareanbietern. Das kann man ja irgendwie
noch bei IT-Leiter verstehen, wenn du für die Koordinierung zuständig bist. So,
Ursachen-Analyse und Fehlerbehebung bei Hardware-Software-Problemen, das ist nichts
für einen IT-Leiter. Das ist auch schwachsinnig. So, Verantwortlich für die Überwachung von
Netzwerkkonfigurationen, Servern, Workstations, Netzwerkausrüstung, Bubbx, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was Bubbx ist, ist es Telefonanlage, Telefonanlagen, E-Mail-Konten, zugrunde liegende Server-Desktop-Infrastruktur.
Die sollen in der Lage sein, eine Ursachen-Analyse für ein Problem durchzufinden. Das hört
noch nicht auf, es geht noch weiter, es geht noch weiter. Kenntnisse der Netzwerk-Infrastruktur,
entschließlich, Verkabelung, drahtlose Netzwerke, Netzwerkswitches, Warnlan, Domain-Controller,
Active Directory, Firewall, VPN-Anwendung. Vorbereitung und Durchführung von vorbeugenden
Wartungsplänen für die gesamte IT-Hardware und Software. Führung bei der Festlegung
des Projektumfangs, der technischen Strategie, der Kosten, des Budgets und der Anforderung
an die Personellen. Ausarbeitung von Richtlinien und Verfahren für die IT-Abteilung. Verwaltung
des Disaster Recovery Prozesses und Sicherstellung regelmäßiger Backups. Aktualisierung der
Richtlinien und Verfahren in Bezug auf die PCE-Konformität. Du bist übrigens auch noch
verantwortlich für Datensicherheit und Cybersecurity. Sie müssen sich außerdem über die neuesten
Hotel-Technologien und Sicherheitsrisiken auf dem Laufen halten. Sie müssen in der
Lage sein, andere von der Geschäftsleitung zugewiesene IT- oder systembezogene Aufgaben
zu erfüllen. Das ist jetzt auch Punktsternchen. Wie viel IT-Abteilung wollen sie? Einen Mann,
was soll der alles können? Ja, alles. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was sie suchen, aber die
suchen definitiv kein Leiter-IT. Die haben da drin drei Aufgaben, die auch für ein Leiter-IT
zu treffen. Aber der Rest ist das, was eigentlich die Leute machen, die du leitest. Und selbst
das, dass du für das alles verantwortlich bist, ist auch eine fragwürdige Sache. Weil
gerade Security und die restlichen Sachen in einer Verantwortungsposition zu verheiraten,
ist natürlich fragwürdig, weil du hast dann einen gewissen Konflikt. Deswegen ist ja oft
mal Security auch so ein bisschen ausgelagert, wenn du beispielsweise dafür bist, dass Software
pünktlich live geht und du gleichermaßen zuständig bist für Security. Was wiegt mehr,
dass es sicher ist oder dass es pünktlich rauskommt? Deswegen macht man sowas nicht
in einer Position. Es geht übrigens noch weiter. Wenn ihr jetzt denkt, das war's, ne, ne.
Mindestens drei Jahre Berufserfahrung im Bereich IT erforderlich. Also ganz ehrlich, wenn
du das wirklich findest, da reichen aber drei Jahre nicht. Da brauchst du einen mit 20
Jahren Berufserfahrung. Hands-on-Mentalität, Innovationsbereitschaft sowie Mut zu neuem
Denken, freundlicher und geduldiger Umgang mit Mitarbeitern. Wir gucken, was sie bieten.
Flexible Arbeitszeiten, teilweise Möglichkeit von Homeoffice. Ok, das heißt wahrscheinlich
so gut wie gar nicht. Kleines hochmotiviertes Team. Weiterentwicklungsmöglichkeiten. Die
Möglichkeit mehrere einzigartige Unternehmen zur technologischen Benchmark. Moment. Ist
das jetzt ist das ein Vorteil für mich? Ist das jetzt ein Vorteil für mich? Ich mein.
Nicht so wirklich, oder? Wir gucken mal kurz. Wir gucken mal kurz, was sie für. Oh ne, das
sind andere, oder? Das sind die. Und Logo. Die haben kein Logo oder was? Logo. Das ist
wahrscheinlich die übergeordnete Geschichte. Was? Also das war der Hammer, oder? Das ist
echt mal der Hammer, dieses Ding. Also jetzt mal ernsthaft, ich glaube, eine abgedrehtere
Stellenanzeige haben wir noch nie gehabt. Gehalt. Was weiß ich? Gibt's nicht. Ja,
das ist das ist typischer Stabster und Gebate. 2,50 Euro die Stunde. A weird champ.
Morgen kommt da noch ein bisschen mehr zu. So. Dann habe ich noch was gesehen, was mich
ein bisschen verwirrt hat. Der Project Manager bei Otto. Deutsche Otto Lahn. Die suchen einen
agilen Projekt Manager. Das Problem ist nur. Nein, das stand nichts vom Gehalt drinnen.
Das Problem ist nur, ich gebe das jetzt mal, da werde ich nämlich morgen auch ein bisschen
was zu erzählen. Die wollen, dass du in dieser Position als Agile Scrum Master agierst und
als Projektleiter. Bin ich der einzige, der das irgendwie widersprüchlich findet? Das
sind eigentlich zwei Sachen, die passen nicht zusammen. Das geht nicht, richtig. Also es
ergibt relativ wenig Sinn. Als Projektleiter bist du da. Also das ist ein bisschen wie
das, was ich vorher, was ich gesagt habe. Vorher, wenn man Security und Verantwortliche
für ein Produkt in einer Person macht, dann hast du so Interessen Konflikt. Aber das
zusammen stelle ich mir schwierig vor. Ja, okay, du könntest vielleicht Projektleiter
davon sein und Scrum Master bei was anderem. Aber ich gehe mal nicht davon aus, dass sie
das damit vorhaben. Das könnten sie machen. Auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich dann
die Frage, also wie viel das deines Tages Pensums so einnimmt. Aber zumindest sind das
zwei Positionen, die schlecht miteinander zu kombinieren sind. Und außerdem, selbst
wenn du das bei dem einen Projekt machst und dann bei dem anderen, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
nachdem das ja alles immer so gerade auf Führungsebene, wo du letztendlich dann auch als Projektleiter
zum Teil deine Berichte machen musst und sonst was, das ist ja alles schon immer so eine
sehr eingeschworene Sache. Ich stelle es mir zumindest sehr schwierig vor, auf der einen
Seite Projektleiter zu sein, selbst wenn es für ein anderes Projekt ist und hier dann
quasi eher eigenverantwortliche Sachen für das Team zu fördern. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass du das gut zusammen machen kannst, aber eigentlich passt das nicht zusammen. Die Beschreibung
ist natürlich auch ein bisschen bescheuert. Optimale Leistungsfähigkeit, das kann man
jetzt so sehen, es ist ja alles ein bisschen philosophischer Ansatz, also jeder versteht
ein bisschen was anderes drum. Aber bei dieser ganzen Scrum Geschichte geht es ja schon ein
bisschen darum, zumindest war das. Ich weiß, ich hatte von euch mal einer das ursprüngliche
Agile Manifest gelesen, ich habe es auch nicht komplett gelesen, also nicht im Original komplett,
aber ich habe mir so die Essenz des Ganzen durchgelesen. Zum Großteil geht es darum,
dass sich Entwickler nicht mehr mit Managern rumschlagen müssen oder besser gesagt, dass
Manager weniger Einfluss auf den Entwickleralltag haben. Das wird man dann zum Beispiel damit
erreichen, dass du das selbst einteilst und koordinierst als Entwickler bzw. über Sprints,
da es trotzdem natürlich Projektmanager gibt, die regelmäßig eingreifen können, in welche
Richtung sich das Projekt bewegt. Aber halt nicht so, dass ihr quasi alle 5 Minuten irgendein
Managertyp am Rechner steht und sagt, wie sieht es denn damit jetzt aus. Also eine der
ursprünglichen Gedanken hinter dieser ganzen agilen Geschichte war, dass Entwickler, um
es jetzt mal in meinen Worten zusammenzufassen, dass Entwickler Ruhe haben vor Managern, was
ich eigentlich ganz sinnvoll finde. Dieses komplette selbstversorgende Ökosystem, was
man heute mit dieser ganzen Agilität darum gemacht hat, geht meines Erachtens nach schon
teilweise an dem vorbei, was man sich ursprünglich mal darunter ausgemalt hat. Oder allein schon,
dass es dann wieder 200 verschiedene Varianten gibt, von Lean bis Safe bis Jet, was fallen
euch noch für super krasse agilen Dinge ein. Keine Ahnung. Wer war von euch letzten Sonntag
dabei, wo wir uns das Video angeguckt haben von diesem Fachinformatiker Heavy Metal Sänger,
der PHP Fehler gefixt hat. Da habe ich doch noch auf Spaß gesagt in dem Video, wie der
kann einfach einen Fehler fixen, ohne Daily Stand-Up und ohne Tickets und ohne Sprint-Meetings
und ohne Kanber an Bord. Der hat einfach einen Fehler gesehen, hat sich eingeloggt auf dem
System, hat den Fehler gefixt und 30 Minuten später oder 2 Stunden später ging der Scheiß
wieder. Also es wird mittlerweile ein riesen, einen heiden Aufwand gemacht um simpelste
Dinge unter diesem quasi Deckmantel der Agilität. Er hat einen ganzen Tag dafür gebraucht, mit
super agilen Geschirrströme rum hätte er 3 Tage dafür gebraucht. Das hat durchaus
alles seine Daseinsberechtigung, aber sobald man das als Glaubensersatz nimmt, artet's
aus. Ja ich muss sagen, von allen Ticketsystemen die ich bisher hatte, also ich sag mal, von
allen schlechten Ticketsystemen die ich bisher bedienen musste, ist Jira noch das am wenigsten
schlechte. Wisst ihr was das schlechteste Ticketsystem war, was ich jemals benutzen
musste? Aber wirklich mit riesem Abstand das schlechteste. Welche ist deiner Meinung nach
das beste Ticketsystem? Ja ich finde Jira nicht schlecht, aber ich finde den Ansatz
mit Ticketsystem immer noch ein bisschen hakelig. Gerade wenn es dann ausartet, dass man das
eben nicht als Dokumentation auf die Schnelle benutzt, sondern dann immer noch mehr Sachen
drum herum gestrickt werden um die Tickets. Ja wisst ihr was das schlechteste Ticketsystem
war, was ich je verwendet habe? Weiß ich, kennt das jemand? Hatte jemand mal die Ehre
mit Helpline arbeiten zu dürfen? Arrowchild schon ja. Helpline ist absolut Cancer. Leider
nein sei froh. Nein U-Track von Jetpins hab ich noch nie ausprobiert. Ja so sieht das
ungefähr aus. Ja hier so siehts aus Leute. So siehts aus. Windows only WPF Anwendung
ist das. Wobei ich glaube mittlerweile gibt es das auch mit einem halbwegs sinnvollen
Webfrontend. Aber ich musste das als Windows only WPF Anwendung verwenden. Ja so sah das
ungefähr auch aus. Der Infotich. Und wisst ihr was das geilste war an Helpline? Wenn du
dir ein Ticket genommen hast, dann konnte niemand anderes dieses Ticket bearbeiten.
Also wenn du dir ein Ticket genommen hast, entweder irgendjemand vom Support der in
einer Schicht gearbeitet hat, dann konnten das keine anderen Leute bearbeiten, wenn
er das vergessen hat zurückzulegen. Und wenn man einen in den Urlaub gefahren ist, ging
das auch nicht. Das lief dann darauf raus, dass es irgendwie 50 Tickets gab für die
gleichen Sachen. Und irgendjemand ist dann auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen und hat
irgendein Aufräumsskript gebastelt, was über die AP geht und Tickets löscht oder schließt,
die doppelte Titel haben und sowas. Also Leute, dieses Ticketsystem ist einfach nur der
aller aller allerletzte Abfuck. Achja und wisst ihr was das schlechteste Wikisystem
ist, was ich jemals verwendet habe? Ich zeig's euch auch wo wir gerade dabei sind.
New Knowledge Management. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jemand schon mal von
euch die Ehre hatte, das zu verwenden. Das ist so schlecht, ihr habt vorne nicht mal
richtige Screenshots. Das ist ein Wiki quasi. Aber das schlechteste Wiki, was ihr euch
vorstellen könnt. Preise, Preise haben ihr auch gewonnen. Ach nee, was es kostet. Allein
schon wenn es keine ordentlichen Demos gibt. Was ist das für ein Bild wieder hier? Was
geht denn mit denen ab? Das ist wirklich das schlechteste Dokumentation.
Nicht Sebaro, Sabio. Das schlechteste Ticket, äh nicht Ticket,
das schlechteste Wiki, was ich je gesehen habe. Und der Witz war, Sabio und Helpline
haben jetzt sogar eine Integration untereinander. Und wisst ihr auch warum? Weil die sich über
unsere Firma wo ich arbeite kennengelernt haben. Wir haben beides diese scheiß Systeme
verwendet und die haben darüber den Kontakt gekriegt jetzt untereinander irgendwelche
Plugin Integrations zu bauen. Aber zum Glück ist beides weg mittlerweile.
Wir haben echt den Hang dazu uns scheiß Software anzuschaffen, aber wenigstens sind wir dann
meistens so schlau, dass wir die nach, sagen wir mal, 2 Jahren Pains Champ wieder entsorgen.
Könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen. Aber beides wirklich absoluter Schrott an Software.
Ah, Komplettermüll. Ja, ist echt so. So, hab ich jetzt eigentlich genug Leute? Hab
ich noch irgendwelche Sachen nicht angeguckt, die jemand geschickt hat oder so? Vielleicht
haben ja Mod-Mod-Check Leute was mitbekommen. Max, du hast noch nicht gesagt, welcher Bankenturm
in Frankfurt der hässlichste ist. Ganz ehrlich, wahrscheinlich werden das die wenigsten nachvollziehen
können, aber ich bin der Meinung, das EZB-Gebäude sieht kacke aus, weil es so unförmig ist.
Ja, das da. Das mag zwar architektonisch voll geil sein, aber ich finde das sieht kacke
aus, weil das so unförmig aussieht. Sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine PS4. Hier sieht's
aus wie eine PS4. Aber ansonsten. Ok, mal gucken. Wir fallen gar nicht alle ein. Ok.
Commerzbank. Wer hat es hässlich, den westlichsten Turm? Keine Ahnung, ich finde die Stadtansicht
von Frankfurt allgemein richtig cool. Ich würde eigentlich sagen, da ist nichts hässlich.
Der Messerturm ist eh das beste. Das ist das, was hier hinten rausguckt, den man jetzt gar
nicht sieht. Was? Union Investment Frankfurt. Ja, ok, das sieht wirklich aus wie ein Knast,
aber da ist auch schon ein bisschen älter. Und das ist ja in Frankfurt, der Verhältnis
ist ja nicht mal wirklich großartiger. So nicht mal sonderlich groß, oder? Aber in Frankfurt
ist schon so, gerade wenn es nachts wird oder so, ist schon nice. Jeden Tag hinfahren sagt,
aber der Bahnturm. Ja, ich entscheide mich für den Bahnturm tatsächlich. Den sehen wir
hier aber gar nicht, oder? Doch, der hier ist der Bahnturm. Der Bahnturm ist eigentlich
am Hauptbahnhof. Der müsste ein bisschen hinten drin dahinter sein, hier so. Ist er das? Also
ich muss sagen, die alte EZB, das Gebäude fand ich auch cool. Das hier. Das da, wo
das Euro-Zeichen davor ist. Ja, ist witzig, es gibt eigentlich nur Frankfurt. Ich hab
keine Ahnung. Hat Berlin irgendwie hoch, also Wolkenkratzer? Also München wahrscheinlich
nicht. Hamburg wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Hat Berlin? Berlin hat einen Fernsehturm.
Aber ansonsten? Berlin ist leider ein Shithole. Also ich war in meinem Leben einmal in Berlin
und ja, das kann ich bestätigen, ich hab mich direkt an Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof erinnert
gefühlt, als ich da ausgestiegen bin. Was, das Goldene Haus? Sieht aus wie ein Kackhaufen.
Hä? Was ist das Goldene Haus, meinst du das hier? Das müsste die Kommerzbank sein, oder?
Nee. Moment, das ist die alte EZB, nee. Ich bin grad verwirrt. Das ist, nee. Ach, keine
Ahnung. Das ist die alte EZB hier? Frankfurter Sparkasse, Goldene Haus. Naja, zumindest finde
ich Frankfurt an sich ganz nett. Ich hab ja auch schon auf Twitter mal gepostet, wie
ich da morgens... Das ist übrigens die Brücke, wo ich dann morgens drü... Nee, warte mal.
Das hier hinten, nee, nee, nee, nee. Das hier hinten müsste die Brücke sein, wo ich
drüber laufe normalerweise morgens. Hier, hier hinten. Nicht die hier. Ich laufe über
diese alte Mainbrücke, glaube ich, die hier hinten. Gibt irgendwie drei Stück. Und das
sieht wirklich cool aus. Gerade wenn du morgens, also ich sag mal mal so jetzt um die Jahreszeit
steigst du nicht am Hauptbahnhof aus. Nee, ich steig meistens am Südbahnhof aus, dass
ich ein Stückchen laufen kann. Das sieht cool aus. Gerade so morgens, wenn's jetzt noch
nachts ist und du quasi so in diese, in die Lichter von der Stadt, in der Innenstadt rein
läufst, das hat was. Auf der anderen Seite, ich kann euch auch so sagen, das wird relativ
schnell langweilig, wenn man das öfters macht und dann überwiegen die negativen Sachen.
Weil Frankfurt an sich ist nicht sonderlich angenehm. Ich mein, ein Vorteil hat Frankfurt...
Ich mach mal kurz hier die Karte auf. Ein Vorteil hat Frankfurt ja tatsächlich, wenn
du hier bist am Hauptbahnhof... Warte mal. So, wenn du hier am Hauptbahnhof bist, so,
auf dieser Ecke... Äh... Finde mich grad nicht wirklich zurecht. Hier ist die alte
Oper. Hier unten ist die Hanauer Landstraße. Moment. Hier. Ich muss weiter, ich muss weiter
reinzoomen. Also du kannst eigentlich auf dieser Ecke hier, Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, ähm, dann
zur Zeil hoch. Wo ist die? Ich bin grad voll orientierungslos, aber die Richtung müsste
auch stimmen. Die Zeil. Da. Also auf diesem Dreieck. Also auf diesem Dreieck. Zeil Altstadt
Hauptbahnhof. So auf diesem Dreieck. Du kannst da quasi geboren werden, arbeiten, überleben
und sterben. Und du hast alles, was du brauchst. Vom Krankenhaus bis zum... Okay, Krankenhaus
ist glaub ich ein Tückchen weiter. Vom Krankenhaus bis zum Friedhof. Na doch, dann müssen wir
das ein bisschen größer machen. Aber ihr wisst doch, also da ist wirklich einfach alles.
Und hier ist... Alles. Und hier ist, wie Haftbefehl schon gesungen hat, Frankfurt-Rotlicht-Milieu.
Wobei Kaiserstraße ist eigentlich nicht mehr. Kaiserstraße ist heute eine Mischung aus
Pizzerias, Steakläden und Friseuren. Eher hier oben drüber. Taunusstraße. Taunusstraße
und Goethe-Straße. Goethe-Straße ist auch hier irgendwo. Kann man das immer nicht genau
merken. Ne, das ist so das... Das hier ist wirklich eines der beschissenen Snacken in
Frankfurt. Gegenüber vom Hauptbahnhof raus. Taunusstraße, Nidderstraße. So diese Ecke
hier. Die ist einfach nur eklig. Die ist... Ja, diese Ecke hier. Das ist einfach nur abartig.
Hier so. Ja. Da war schon ein paar Maschiner essen. Was hat der für Bewertungen? Ah, ganz
okay. So. Ja, ist im Prinzip so. Also du hast ein paar Dinger in Frankfurt, da ist das so.
Hat jemand eine Ahnung, in welchem Feld man in einem IT-Bereich gehen könnte, wenn man
Wert auf Karriere legt und auch laufend mehr Verantwortung übernehmen möchte, IT-Consulting
im Auskommen? Naja, der beste Bereich ist der Bereich, in dem du Ahnung hast. Und der
Bereich, von dem du Ahnung hast, ist in der Regel der Bereich, der dich am meisten interessiert.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was interessiert dich denn so. Das ist glaube ich in der IT wahrer als
in den meisten anderen. Ganz ehrlich, ich würde nicht SAP machen, wenn es mich abfacken
würde, nur für die Karriere. Du bist da drin wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich gut und musst
jeden Tag was machen, was dich anpisst. Ich würde gucken, dass ich in dem Bereich, der
mich interessiert, was machen kann, weil ich in dem Bereich Ahnung habe. Ja gut, und mehr
Verantwortung übernehmen ist erstmal die Frage, ob du dich jetzt dafür eignest. Beispielsweise
so was wie Teamleiter, Projektleiter, vielleicht mal später dann auch ein bisschen mehr zu
machen. Verantwortung übernehmen wollen ist das erste, Verantwortung auch sinnvoll übernehmen
können, muss man da auch mal fernes halber sagen, hat auch nicht jeder das Händchen
für. Also es gibt bestimmt mehr Leute, die als Chef unfähig sind als Fähige. Also da
muss man auch so ein Händchen dafür haben. Ich weiß, ich kann es ja mal sagen, was ist
denn der Bereich, der dir am meisten Spaß macht? Was ist der Bereich, der dich interessiert?
Cobol. Naja, ich glaube es gibt kaum jemand, der Cobol wirklich mag. Cobol Enjoyer. Durchschnittlicher
Cobol Enjoyer. Wo sind sie? Gut, wenn ich die Auswahl hätte, machst du C++ oder machst
du Cobol, dann würde ich auch Cobol machen. Du bist derzeit im IT-Audit tätig. Ich wüsste
jetzt gar nicht, was auditierst du denn? Ich wüsste jetzt gar nicht, was man da so macht,
aber das ist schon mal gut, wenn man das erkennt. Will selbst auch Probleme lösen, könnte
mir auch vorstellen, ein paar Jahre als Software-Entwickler zu arbeiten. Aber auch nicht für 10 Jahre,
aber finde mich derzeit noch im 5. Semester. Achso, ja gut, dann ist natürlich schwer zu
sagen, aber selbst im Studium kannst du dir zumindest schon vorstellen, so grob nach dem
Motto, macht dir Programmieren Spaß? Ja, nein. Ja, das ist natürlich dann schwierig
zu sagen. Stell so, danke schön für den Zapp. Du prüfst SAP-Systeme. SAP ist wunderbar
zum Geldverdienen. Aber wie du schon selbst gesagt hast, wenn ich es keinen Bock macht,
wo wir wieder bei der eigentlichen Geschichte sind. Es hat keinen Sinn, Sachen nur zu machen,
weil sie theoretisch Geld bringen, aber wenn man kotzen muss, wird man da auch nicht besser
und hat keinen Bock drauf. Also ich bin mittlerweile der Meinung, man sollte in dem Bereich arbeiten,
der am meisten Spaß macht, weil man da am meisten Ahnung davon hat, dadurch wieder
bessere Möglichkeiten hat dort zu arbeiten und dementsprechend noch mehr Ahnung von
bekommt. Also ich habe mittlerweile so eine ganz gute Mischung gefunden, eben aus dem,
was ich jetzt mache. Ich kann meine Programmier-Skills einbringen, aber auch meine bestimmt mittlerweile.
Ich will es jetzt nicht übertreiben, aber sagen wir mal so ungefähr 15-jährige Nilux-Erfahrung.
Das in Kombination ist wunderbar. Das sage ich nicht, wo ich arbeite. Aber was ich mache,
ich arbeite als DevOps-Engineer. Ich habe da mal ein Video zugemacht. Zwei Videos, die
dazu einst ganz interessant sind. Das da und das da. Das ist so, das kann alles bedeuten,
deswegen habe ich da auch ein Video darüber gemacht, was ich genau mache. Das kann tatsächlich
alles bedeuten. Zumal ja die ursprüngliche DevOps-Idee heutzutage ein bisschen weitergefasst
wird. Die ursprüngliche DevOps-Idee war ja eigentlich mal, also ursprünglich Programmierer
sind eine Anwendung und betreiben sie später auch selbst. Also quasi man programmiert
es und man ist dann nachher auch für den Betrieb verantwortlich. Das war ja mal der
ganz ursprüngliche DevOps-Ansatz. Heute geht es da im größten Teil eher um Entwicklertools
und sowas. Ich mache ja zum größten Teil Versionsverwaltung und Linux-Geschichten
in Kombination mit ein bisschen Release-Management und letztendlich auch noch ein bisschen mehr
links und rechts alles mögliche. Aber ich habe da ein Video drüber gemacht. Es gibt
auch Big Brain Engineers, Cloud-Native, FIFAT-Developers, Druckerpatronen. Ich habe tatsächlich letztens
Druckerpatronen gemacht. Aber bei mir daheim. Weil ich wieder mal das Problem hatte, ich
musste steuertechnisch was ausdrucken und mein Drucker hat mal wieder nicht getan.
Das ist jedes Jahr der gleiche Scheiß. Leute, warum sagt ihr mir da nicht Bescheid?
Was ist jetzt hier? Uhrzeit? Was ist jetzt? Schon spät. Oh danke für den Prime-Sub.
Das kann ich nicht aussprechen. Oh nein, ich bin nicht in der Lage das auszusprechen.
Was? Das kann ich nicht aussprechen. Aber trotzdem, danke für den Prime-Sub.
Ich schaue seit Wochen wieder alle deine alten YouTube Videos von 2007 bis 2017. Du kannst
ja auch meine aktuellen Videos angucken. Da gibt es ja auch welche. Morgen gibt es ein
neues. Müdige. Ach, die tauscht ja auch. Dann ist ja alles
Bock. Okay Leute, schon spät. Braggle. Nein, nicht wirklich. Bedge heute ist angesagt.
Sehr selten, ja. Wir sehen uns Leute. Wahrscheinlich bis morgen. Oder morgen mache ich erst mal
so. Bis denn, CU. Bring es demnächst, könnt ihr auf YouTube auch noch rein subben. Ich
werde YouTube Memberships aktivieren. Mehr Stonks.
Bis denn, machts gut, CU.